very quickly steve bannon was found
guilty of contempt of congress and uh
well i guess that's the news it was kind
of to be expected steve bannon was
arguing executive privilege but when he
was in was on trial his defense team
actually didn't bring up any witnesses
so many people are thinking this is some
kind of bigger play here that there's
maybe a strategy to go to a higher court
we'll see we'll talk about that of
course but this
whole political circumstance around the
bind administration and democrats
targeting former administration
officials with arrest and investigation
well it it brings us to a dangerous
territory with this other story last
night lee zeldin he's a republican
congressman running for governor someone
tried to kill him now i'm seeing all
these news outlets saying allegedly
tried to stab but there's a photo of the
guy holding a blade in his hand it's got
like two-pronged blade and zelda is
grabbing his arm to hold him back i'm
like you can see the guy on camera like
try to go at his neck so i'm like
attempted or alleged oh i attempted yes
but like alleged i was like you why
would you watch the guy do it
crazy crazy stories man i did some uh
cursory digging into this guy's
background and i think he might be i
could be wrong about this but just like
a default liberal kind of guy like a
regular guy doesn't pay attention to
politics all that much but votes
democrat
radicalized by the january 6 committee
and democrat rhetoric around extremist
maga stuff because we know that
democrats have been funding gop
candidates while simultaneously claiming
it's an existential threat
so we'll get into that we'll talk about
that we also got probably the best story
ever it has been leaked or apparently
it's being reported that donald trump
should he win in 2024 he will purge up
to 50 000 government employees and it's
funny because the media and the
democrats are like oh no
he's going to dismantle our government
and i'm like yeah
yeah all right
so we'll get in all that before we get
started my friends why don't you head
over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work and
if you go to that members only section
you can see the wonderful marjorie
taylor green we had her on last night
giving her thoughts on
what the republicans may do in 2022 uh
or say 2023 in january when they win as
it pertains to
the election in 2020. so that'll be
really interesting as a member you can
watch all of that as well as our new
shows like tales from the universe world
cass castle is being expanded into a
larger comedy show that will be tuesday
i think we're doing tuesday at 7 p.m but
i also want to shout out so again become
a member i'll also add we don't use
paypal anymore we switch to parallel
economy co-founded by dan bongino
support companies that don't hate you
and tim kest but i want to give a shout
out to our good friend john rich you
guys probably know john rich he is a
superstar country star he has released a
new song called progress and the music
video and the song itself
amazing and it's phenomenal and um you
know we were like we got it we got to
help john hit number one he's already
number one oh yeah john rich has already
hit number one on the itunes top charts
with his song progress and do you know
what his song is about
it's about rioters and extremists
burning down cities destroying families
and he's saying keep if that's progress
keep it away from me the song's
absolutely fantastic the video is really
really great as well so shout out john
we're big fans uh
i guess congratulations you're number
one you didn't you didn't need us to set
you up but we really really wanted to
joining us today to talk about all those
stories as well as a bunch of other
stories is constantine kissing
hey who are you what do you do man i'm a
former stand-up comedian turned youtuber
and uh just written a book they're
called an immigrant's love letter to the
west which is uh sunday times bestseller
as of today which i'm pleased about wow
but i co-host a youtube show uh called
trigonometry and it's two things we
interview people so it's serious
interviews and also we do something
called the raw show which is me and my
co-host francis uh both comics just
joking around the events of the day we
do every ridiculous accent under the sun
just to make fun of everything and don't
take anything too seriously right on we
also have another story uh twitter
banned the word groomer
they were like it's a slur against lgbtq
people so you can't use it it's like
okay it's getting a little weird but
we'll talk about that too for sure we
also have hannah claire she's back hi
yeah i'm hannah claire brimley i'm a
writer for timcast.com actually the
person who wrote the story we're going
to be using steve
nothing like having your boss read your
articles on yeah there's a typo here oh
no you know i'm always like get a copy
editor too
there was a show when i first started
where there's a typo in one of my sub
headlines and the next week chris carr
joined us so
i'll just look up and glare if we see
something if i get fired live on air
it'll be exciting
oh hi everyone what are you doing
i'm building a straw out of this honey
there's these little packets of honey
that are shaped like a straw so i was
just clipping off an end and stirring my
coconut water into this delicious coffee
oh cold brew i'm ian crossland by the
way constantine i'm looking forward to
talking about your book what is it about
really quick before we get going very
very quickly uh i am worried that in the
west we're moving in the direction of
the society that i grew up in which was
the late soviet union in terms of many
other things that i'm seeing and i
wanted to give people in the west a
warning uh not to go down that road
because it's not a very good one thanks
for writing that we'll talk more about
it soon i feel like i'm interrupting
everyone this evening i interrupted
hannah claire to bring her on the show
which is great because she kept trying
to keep her from being nervous and then
ian i'm casting it over to him he's
trying to gnaw on this funny thing i'm
sorry everyone i had it coming i'm just
here in the corner pushing buttons like
i always do let's get going i'm excited
all right the first story on a friday of
course it's actually kind of big news
steve bannon's been found guilty of two
charges in contempt of congress trial
it's a minimum of two years for each
count but would they really give him
that long some are saying it's going to
be two months he's going to get the bare
minimum they're going to say two r two
two uh two months to run concurrently
for both counts but we'll see the story
steve bannon said we may have lost a
battle here today but we are not going
to lose this war
bannon is the former executive chairman
of breitbart news as well as a former
advisor to president trump the
conviction comes after a four-day trial
during which the justice department
argued bannon believes he's above the
law and showed he chose to show his
contempt for congress
congress's authority and its process by
refusing to comply with the january 6
committee's subpoenas
well instead of just reading this let me
just ask hannah claire what what's going
on with the story are there any other
developments or you know what's your
reporting on it yeah well the major
thing is that he has been following this
line that he
was exercising executive privilege from
president trump that trump's lawyers had
encouraged him not to
testify before the committee not to
submit any documents and they're saying
this is within you know official
protocol it's acceptable the january 6
committee says no this he knew he was
supposed to comply with the subpoenas he
has to turn over the documents he needed
to testify you have to remember that the
january 6 committee has subpoenaed 100
people the only for other person to be
indicted is uh
peter peter navarro thank you um and
throughout the trial is a four-day trial
and we had
basically the justice department's
saying this is ridiculous it's simple he
was supposed to be there and we had uh
bannon's attorneys arguing that no
there's precedent in the way and also he
was in the middle of negotiating terms
we've seen a couple other people i think
mo brooks said yeah i'll testify before
january 6 but i want it to be televised
i want it to be recorded there are
people who are
uncomfortable with the way this
investigation is being carried out so a
lot of the story or a lot of the feeling
is that they're trying to make an
example of bannon right here the first
that comes to mind is uh constantine is
this becoming soviet-esque
yeah i don't know too much about i i
think it's scary in a different way to
me as a complete outsider who maybe
doesn't follow the legal details but
just seeing how divided this country is
and i love america i think it's a
brilliant place but seeing how angry and
people both sides are trying to destroy
each other right down burn everything
down to the ground is very worrying
because it's not just about america like
we everywhere in the world in the uk
where i live we import all of this stuff
and then we start doing the same thing
to each other so it's really really
worrying the way things are going man
i think um
when you have the previous
administration
and the rival political party
arresting the
when you have the current administration
sorry and rival democratic party
arresting their rivals and the previous
administration yeah we're there man so
steve bannon is
let me put this away the january 6
committee is a sham it's it's it's fake
it's lies they included me in their
evidence
so so right away i'm already like
everybody i know most people listening
know this but um were you the shaman guy
no no they they claimed that uh trump
supporters were encouraging people to go
down and get violent
and they put me in their montage of
people because
i commented on a comment trump made as i
was reading a news article i said donald
trump says this will happen and it's
called for his supporters so they put me
in this montage because their goal is
just to lie and drive escalation
what we've been seeing the democrats do
is they've been putting money into
trump-supported candidates like trump
endorsed candidates
so that they win because they believe
come november they will then beat the
trump candidate right
they're coming out on january 6 and
saying it's an existential threat to our
country but then funding the message and
propping it up
so steve bannon gets a subpoena and
first and foremost he didn't just say
screw you he said
the president has executive privilege
meaning you know we don't have to comply
with congress
there should have been
there's got to be some negotiation right
like if the pres if they're they're
arguing that trump's not the president
therefore doesn't count but i'm like but
he was like you lose your executive
privilege the month out of office then
we'd be going after every single
president ever why aren't they going
after bush over over the middle eastern
war stuff
this is purely i think we're getting
into uh authoritarian
fascistic communistic whatever you want
to call it
where
there's the uniparty neocons and neolibs
and if you oppose them they will destroy
you and the the the the people who work
in government are just gonna you know
turn along with it well let's remember
that the two republicans on this
committee are adam kinzinger and liz
cheney who are notoriously unpopular in
the republican party i mean they'll say
it's bipartisan but you have to question
why they didn't oppose
appoint someone who had a more
opposing perspective from the democrats
that are leaving this committee it's
clearly not something that they were
interested in doing i think with
bannon ultimately
he has just become
a man with a target on his back they
know that if they can make this adviser
to trump who
is outside he he represents to a lot of
normal americans a lot of normal liberal
americans sort of the fear of who trump
is cultivating or who trump works with
and i think by
fi i mean i think if he goes to jail for
let's say 60 days they also can fine him
between a hundred and hundred thousand
dollars so if they hit him with the 200
000 fine they put them in jail for 60
days they have sort of landed an arrow
on on bannon and that's really all this
is tim can i steal man like i'm just
curious because i always like playing
devil's advocate is what i do on our
show so if you just take the steel man
version of the democrat argument right
that what wouldn't they say what
happened was on january 6 with an
attempt to overthrow democracy and we
have to make sure this never happens
again which is why we're doing this is
that what they would say
so one more time the democrats are
arguing that the
january 6th it's an attempt to overthrow
democracy
and they have to follow the legal
process to make sure that never happens
again that's essentially that that's
what there are and what's wrong with
that argument it's not real
so they're trying to so i'll give you an
example using me
they're trying to argue there was an
organized effort a conspiracy to do to
you know overthrow the us government
even though the fbi says that's not true
initially they did now you've got
seditious conspiracy charges and it's
and it's it's just i think it's it's
it's all fake for a variety of reasons
one you've got they had this unnamed
co-conspirator and the guy actually ex
like revealed himself saying like here's
the chat messages we were saying no
violence it was like it was like
criticizing people who are arguing for
violence you've got ray epps for
instance this guy who's out in the
street on camera telling people to go in
no charges the media defends them the
reality is
there were no cops
uh
protecting the perimeter like there was
no substantial police force there were
some cops police opened the door to the
capitol did you know that yeah police
opened the door they fanned people in
there was a riot at one side and there
were people shoving their way in some
areas and maybe half of the people who
walked in were invited in by the police
the cops opened the doors waved them in
oh no all of this i agree with and i
totally accept i guess what i'm saying
is i think from the from their
perspective a more plausible explanation
is they thought donald trump was a
hitler
right yeah and then his supporters
stormed the capital
storm inverted commerce well i mean if
if their perspective is based on the
fact that they're wrong oh no i don't
think they can believe unicorns
i'm not disagreeing with you i'm just
saying i think the reason that they're
behaving in this way is they decided
evil hitler and his supporters did this
no they're they're funding they're
funding these people you think it's
deliberate i mean it's i don't think
it's reported
fact that the democrats governor
association put 1.16 million dollars
into who's dan cox uh yeah dan cox of
maryland he's running as a republican
for governor they're literally funding
the people they claim are threatening
democracy so there's no way they believe
that's true it's not monolithic though
the democrats just it gets kind of vague
because when margery taylor green was
here last night listen you guys talking
she was saying the democrats want to
she's talking about the democrat
congressmen and women but when you say
the democrats you're talking about like
the governor's association yeah
national committee and and the voters
are a bunch and sometimes the voters
themselves ignorant people who are
marching in lockstep with fake news
because the people that
assign themselves democrat when they
vote are considered democrats but
they're not the democratic congress
people so it's it's a lot of discipline
we're talking about the political party
it's just such a large disparity
it is like some want this some want that
some think it was no no you're
this is not not the point the point is
there's democratic leadership and
infrastructure and the infrastructure
and power and leadership and money is
has an agenda and a goal true but to say
that because the democratic governors
association is funding uh trump
candidates doesn't mean that all
democrats are funding trump candidates
no it means the democratic establishment
is applying resources in that direction
in many ways while simultaneously the
same establishment is screaming that
this is the end of demand so who
controls the democratic establishment i
mean you can point to a handful of
people for a while it was hillary
clinton i don't uh uh you can say barack
obama was the leader of the party
there's a bunch of people involved
there's john podesta but i don't know
you know at this point it seems like
it's fractured and falling apart and so
that could be uh why it seems chaotic
and it seems so insane it used to very
much be that there was there were
prominent individuals that you knew were
running the show if you take a look at
uh back in 2020 when when uh the boston
globe reported on the war games they
were doing you can see who it was it was
hillary clinton's campaign staff former
campaign staff it's joe biden and but
you look at the bite administration and
it feels like they're the democrat party
is a chicken with its head cut off
running around randomly spraying things
around the body is still there you know
it's still moving around but it's lost
purpose so that's why i think it's it's
so dejected and insane
but uh yeah simply put the democratic
voter base is is is the uh the voter of
believing jesse smallett sorry
that these are the people who believe
jesse smallette right but this is
exactly what my point was going to be
because what i see on the left is a
bunch of overreactions sort of like like
aoc every time something happens like it
was like a terrorist attack in her head
when someone just like made some
offensive i got to stop you well i mean
yes but she fabricated the story from
january 6. oh of course that's what i'm
saying it's not an overreaction it's
it's deliberate fabrication
could be both could be both right that's
that's kind of what i'm like a big
problem on the left that i see is people
exaggerating the nature of everything
that happens they're like they're so
obsessed with being a victim everything
makes them extra victim and that's why i
was just asking the question right
because i don't know that much about
this i was just sort of posing as a
question which is is it not their
perspective that this thing that nearly
happened would have been absolutely
awful and they really really really
really really want to prevent it from
happening again no that would be like
the more reasonable argument but
but just
it's just you don't agree well no i mean
it's when you look at aoc's story from
january 6th oh it's [ __ ] but but i
mean totally fabricated i agree not just
bs she altered the timeline of what
happened right she literally fabricated
the circumstances
there's which people who have been
through trauma do right
fabrication stories memories
a day later absolutely that's what
happens that's why you can't get
witnesses she faked having handcuffs the
other day yeah that's what that's what
people do man but that's that's not
trauma that's malicious evil
it could be both well it's about to come
on like it could be lazy staring at a
politician who has overtly and
repeatedly fabricated things have been
caught doing it i agree and and and
you're like well maybe it's you know
it's not trauma she's doing it on
purpose because it gives her power it
gives her followers she gets attention
from it
example here is that she is got there's
a couple video clips of her changing her
accent based on who she's speaking
seriously right like for democrats have
been doing that for years they talk down
to black people when they're talking to
them we're not right so
the fact that i mean if you would make
the assumption that the the numerous
times aoc's fabricated stories and i i
can give you like five at the top of my
head that it's all accidental or the
result of trauma that is a conspiracy
theory like that is that is on par with
like you might as well go buy a lottery
ticket because if all those things are
coincidences you've won the lottery by
now no the simple solution is
if it walks like a duck if it quacks
like a duck you've got a duck aoc she
lies she lied when she led the protest
in the financial district to get amazon
booted from new york and then when
amazon jumped out of new york dropping i
think what was it like 30 billion
dollars in revenue over 10 years she
goes i have nothing to do with that it's
not even my district you look at january
6th you look at changing her accent you
look at faking her handcuffs the woman
literally just fabricates things with a
smile on her i agree with you so it's to
say that's the result of trauma though
no i'm not saying it's all the result of
trauma
what i'm saying is sometimes people uh
exaggerate their experience sometimes
deliberately sometimes not do you see
what i'm saying oh sure sure but like so
i think with her it's both but there's a
difference between she's a politician of
course there's a difference between
exaggerating and fabrication
right exaggerating would be like
if aoc said
that um when the cop knocked on her door
and said where is she she got scared
because she didn't know this person was
and felt threatened by it i would have
been like that's an exaggeration
probably instead she claimed she thought
that the writers got to her a full hour
before the writers breached the building
and no one had any idea they would have
done that that's a fabrication not an
exaggeration like no one even came in
the building she turned one circumstance
into a different circumstance because
she she had hindsight she knew the
circumstance of the day and she knew
most people did not know the timeline so
when i saw that story i said this
doesn't make sense when she thought they
got in her building and what did we hear
from conservatives they were like aoc
wasn't even in the capital the fact
checkers come out and say the capital is
connected to those buildings by
underground tunnels and then i said and
her story took place an hour before
anyone breached the capitol in the first
place did she was she psychic did she
know it was gonna happen the reason the
cops went to her door was because they
were evacuating over a bomb scare she
did not know in fact she had just gone
up for lunch or something
why was she hiding in the bathroom
she fabricated the story when someone
came and knocked on her door she claimed
she went hid in the bathroom why
there was no breaching at the capitol
she's just sitting in her office one day
and someone knocks the noise she's like
i better go hide in the bathroom because
she fabricated the story
i agree with you that witnesses to
crimes can under stress misremember
things and things become
uh confusing or hyperbolic but
with aoc she has a track record i mean i
still think about her photos at the
southern border where she's crying and
it turns out there's nothing there like
she is
a master of political theater and i
think in certain points that served her
well and she knows that to a certain
extent her voter base isn't going to
question her anyways like she could say
anything and they'd be like you go girl
let me see what your skincare routine
might decide to play devil's advocate
has got me defending
i had no intention of doing whatsoever
well let's let's jump to the next next
story the escalation in this check this
out this was uh huge breaking news
yesterday lee zeldin a republican from
new york someone tried to stab him and
they're saying it was an alleged
stabbing and i'm like there's a picture
of the guy holding
i don't know what it's called but it's
got two blades on it in his hand as he's
like
going and then zelda is holding his arm
back you watch the video first the guy
didn't run full speed and jump up he
casually gets up walks up and goes like
this and then gets his arm grabbed
almost like he didn't really want to do
it but i'm not going to say that
he went for it and got taken you know
pulled down thrown down
this dude got released immediately
mm-hmm which leaves zeldan predicted
that night but we're we're talking about
a man
who attempted to assassinate at by at
the at minimum
attempted to stab in the neck a a a
republican running for governor and they
just caught him loose right away how is
it how i thought that only happens in
the uk that's new york state law it's
interesting because lee zeldin one of
his major platforms running he's
challenging kathy hoggle is
that the crime laws in uh in in new york
are terrible and that they don't keep
people safe who need to be kept safe so
it's just irony of irony that he was
like i can tell you he said this at 1 30
in the morning like under new york state
law this man will be released and he was
completely right because he knows the
law he charged him with attempted
second-degree assault
you jump on stage to a sitting member of
congress
when a sending member of congress is
there with a blade in your hand and go
for his neck and that that's it
i'm i i
i've heard some like arguments that he
was actually reaching for the the
microphone and that the blade
because the governor uh um zeldin said
that he said you're done to him before
he came at him maybe he was gonna try
and grab the mic why does he have a
weapon in his hand see if you're
approaching a guy with a weapon it
doesn't make any sense attempted murder
i've heard other people say well those
are like self-defense key chains they're
not that serious but it's like why would
we sell them to women for self-defense
that's what they are if you're attacked
at night they want you be able to hit
your attacker and have more force i mean
it's it's a very strange thing to do and
it is even stranger to me that he's just
on the show do you have a picture of the
blade yep yeah let me see if i can pull
it up on twitter this is wild i'm not uh
i'm not gonna provide a defense for a
guy who jumped on stage
holding a blade and going after a
sitting member of congress and telling
him he's done that allegedly i don't
know
yeah so it's uh like
who knows what that is is that i don't
know what it's called people probably
know what it's called it's got two
spikes on it you hold it between your
fingers they're self-defense chains yeah
yeah
yeah
and in the in the video you can see his
arm go up and around towards the neck
and that's what a lot of people reported
that he took a swing at his neck at
zeldin's neck and then they grabbed his
arm and then someone bear hugged him and
pinned him down
you jump on stage wielding a weapon
saying you're done
and then move your arm around with the
blade in it like dude come on
um is there a video of it of the attack
i guess we'll call it an attack there
are some flying along yeah you can't you
can't see that much but you can you can
look it up it's it's a little far away
but you can see him reach for it i just
think regardless this is uh here's what
i think of this guy i did some digging
into his into his background and his
family and stuff trying to find out what
i could about him
i don't know a whole lot
um and this is based on some of his
family but it seems like they're default
democrat types like naive ignorant not
really paying attention
my my personal assumption is that this
guy is probably a dude who watches msnbc
and cnn
hears the rhetoric here's what hulkel
says about zeldin being a big lie trump
insurrectionist type and so he's like i
better do something about this you know
it's like so he so he goes out there
thinking he's gonna stop this guy
radicalization this is what i wrote
about in the newsweek article about
january 6. the reason raskin included me
out of context in his video is to drive
escalation they they so already we have
had people uh people i work with people
who work for me and and people i know
say
they've they saw like the reason that
the newsweek article came to be is
because i got hit up by newsweek and
they said the moment we saw you in that
clip we knew it was like like
something's not right here and they're
like you want to write about this and
there were a bunch of people hit me up
and said like my family saw that and
they were like whoa that's the guy you
watch and had to explain to them that it
was fake that they're lying about this
but it's radicalizing people well this
is the point i made earlier if you
remember when we started with bannon
it's like this worries me because your
country is being radicalized against
itself it's and the two sides are being
encouraged to see each other's enemies
you talk about it in war-like terms it's
a war we have to destroy them and this
is what you end up with people going on
stage trying to stab politicians
although i tell you uh there there are
people on the right who are certainly
saying stuff about like the tree of
liberty and things like that the people
on the left are uh
you you have the establishment left
which is the democratic
they're the ones calling for
conflict they're the ones saying like
arrest them shut them down take away
their votes and then you have the
leftists the socialists who just they've
always won a revolution anyway so
they're like bring it on
then you have the
you know more fringe elements of the
right side that are saying tree of
liberty and crazy stuff like that but
then when you look at the prominent
right and and middle which is unified
it's totally opposed to all the conflict
and violence so
i think the the main issue is
what do we talk about when we talk about
uh the civil war or whatever it's
usually like a national divorce can it
be peaceful and how do we prepare for it
to protect ourselves against attacks not
to attack you look at the left and
they're talking about how to go and
arrest people and shut them and they're
they're mocking bannon they're wielding
the power of the federal government
against the previous administration they
are wielding law enforcement power to
destroy their enemies my worry is though
tim is if you think about this story
right if that politician is republican
right if he gets stabbed
that will radicalize people on the right
as well and this is the process right
you go from one to another to another
and before you know everyone wants to
kill you but but maybe radical
radicalize isn't the right word if we i
mean we literally just saw someone tried
to assassinate brett kavanaugh
these leftist groups
broke the law
and the ag did nothing about it and
everybody asked them like hey you know
this was illegal and he's like don't
care then someone then i i said this if
you do not uphold the law when it comes
to protesting at this home they will
escalate of course and the next step was
the guy showed up with the crowbar and
the rope and the taser or whatever he
had pepper spray really is like a fire
if you don't put it out it just keeps
growing but you don't enforce the law
equally for both sides you have no law
right right so here's what i would say
it's not radicalization when when we
just had two assassination attempts in
the span of like a month or so for for
someone on the right to be like i better
bring a gun with me it's not a
radicalization it's not them saying they
want to kill someone it's them saying i
don't want to be killed i watch the
video i uh i don't think he's trying to
kill him he walked up to him and then he
started talking to him and actually
backed away like a half a foot and then
started to grab at him so it was an
assault but he would have walked up the
blade in his hand yeah he like walked up
and started talking to him
go armed and the other thing to tim's
point is that see his arm go around for
the neck uh they struggled yeah
he lifted he would have killed him if he
wanted to kill him he would have walked
up and killed him that's not true you
don't walk up and start talking to
someone if you want you are wrong in
fact the most effective way to to do it
is to do it slowly uh not on stage and
running at someone immediately gets you
tackled oh yeah his approach for sure
but once he stood got up to him he just
stood there and started talking to him
and then they struggled i'm not gonna
say i know what he was thinking but he
had a blade in his hand and he motioned
for his neck and people often make these
mistakes because they base their views
on movies in a movie you see the guy
jump up and i'm gonna get you when you
look in real life assassinations could
be very very simple and
i'll tell you i'll tell you about uh i
was you ever see those theaters those
theater events where they have the ninja
and uh or actually it's a better example
i'll start this way you ever see those
those comedy routines where there's a bl
a black background on the stage and then
the guy will get fake slashed and then
his body splits because it's actually
two people wearing you know a white
white pants and a white shirt but then
they're wearing all black the the idea
of why ninja wear all black was because
they would do plays
and to make the ninja
not be able to be seen on stage she
would wear all black against a black
backdrop then when they popped out and
did something oh it was a ninja in
reality ninja would dress like a farmer
if you want to infiltrate to assassinate
someone you have to blend in not wear
all black they would do other tricks too
and they would calmly approach not
psychotically run up full speed and
scream
they'd walk up very calmly and smile and
waving so what you're saying is this
guy's a ninja what i'm saying is
that
that right there you cannot determine
whether it was an assassination attempt
because he walked slowly or not it's
true in fact i think walking slowly is
is more is yeah but if the guy like
walks up to you with that thing on his
hand in the street
you'd be worried right for sure if
someone approaches me on the street i'm
worried but right
you're on stage and when this guy gets
up and walks over he's wearing like a
veteran hat they're thinking like what's
happening i'll tell you another story
famous story uh or i should say it may
be apocryphal urban legend
a security guard was in a bank three
guys walk in with with ski masks on and
rifles and and they just walk right up
to him and say drop your gun and he goes
oh he drops it and then they rob the
bank and after they asked the security
guard why didn't you do anything and he
was like i couldn't believe it was
actually happening like i don't know
they was they walked up to me and just
took my gun you want to play have you
want to play this clip zelda oh we can't
we can't play an assassination attempt
on youtube okay that's what you're
saying zelda addressed it and he said
like i could see this guy coming out of
the corner of my eye like i could see
they had he had a hat on that maybe had
a veterans thing but like when this is
happening
you can't really
stop to be like oh i'm gonna reason with
him like you just have to deal with
what's going on like grabbed his wrists
things like that i will also note that
the hocal campaign specifically called
out this event in an email saying like
it's it's a a mega republican bus tour
that big line lee is like like they drew
attention to this event they radicalized
people and then pointed them in this
direction yeah because that's the big i
mean we are a very divided country and
especially in new york you see it as uh
hoco lining up behind a lot of the more
liberal policies that new york has
carried through the pandemic and then
zeldan is an uh vocal trump supporter so
they are a perfect contrast and to have
this become something that's happening
in their state and then for him to
correctly call out that the guy who
attacked him is going to be released
like it doesn't look great but they're
not really looking for a mediation
between these two sides who got hulkel
put there like she was lieutenant
governor under cuomo and then cuomo
resigned she took over so she's running
to be elected she was she assumed the
the spot afterwards
didn't cuomo want to run again or
something i think so yeah he's like i'm
gonna come he's never gonna i'm gonna
run it into the ground this time yeah
but i think this this is the stuff i've
been talking about and it's funny
because you know i'll say something like
i think we're headed towards a civil war
and four years ago people said that was
stupid and then i was a [ __ ] and then i
was like bro i don't know i just read
the atlantic and they were like we
talked to security experts who said the
united states is headed for civil war
we're in a fifth generational world war
right now and we have noir yes the other
day you were arguing that it wasn't now
you're saying it's
very commit convinced we're in a fifth
generational war meaning it's a cyber
war a war of the mind and the spirit and
it is global it's corporations in all
countries making you think it's from
another country it's 14 year olds in
their parents bedroom in the middle of
wherever they live uh and it's everybody
is is not everybody but it is a lot of
people vying for power uh digitally in
in the cyber space
and they want they would love to see the
united states shoot itself but um you
know how do you comment a lot of people
would better
better better thoughts ideas
communication skills better emotions
staying calm i don't know if there's a
there is a way to solve it it's i think
there's
it may end up being some kind of
natural selection phenomenon where those
that are have the the perspicacity to
see what's happening start preparing for
the winter and those that don't will
starve in the winter you know what i
mean i think it's it's more of a common
threat issue if you guys felt that you
like if an alien invasion happened
suddenly we'd stop all this [ __ ]
fighting wouldn't we right no i don't
yeah so either i think we'd give some
people to the aliens we had a pandemic
yeah and
that did not stop it
in the uk it did for about three weeks
and then when we we backed we went back
to the culture war but it did i think a
genuine uh yeah if if aliens came you'd
have the left being like we need to
accept diversity right being like
they're literally invading and they'd be
like you don't know that they're
bringing us technology what if the
aliens are transphobic maybe not first
they would be the right being like hey
these guys aren't so bad they'd wait to
see what cnn told them to feel about the
aliens and then that would be the cult
and the aliens would come down everyone
else would be like what are you doing
the aliens would come down and go to the
uniparty establishment elites and they'd
say we're going to give you immortality
cures for all your diseases we're going
to give you levitation boots tell your
people to serve us and they're going to
go done real real talk though what would
you guys do if aliens came and we're
peaceful and we're like we're here to
co-exist well i wouldn't i don't think
aliens that would come would be peaceful
ever yeah that that doesn't seem like
they're in a situation that they were
and they came and they're like we're
here to help what could you do what
could you do you you do what you're
doing and live your life and and just
co-exist with them you wouldn't want to
destroy them what do you mean coexist
with them well the aliens are like
they're motherships in the sky they're
like we're here we're going to stay here
with you we want to stay here with you
and help you and live amongst you and
they're super peaceful they're beautiful
would you accept it and would you like
okay now we're working if you could
trust them if they were like we're here
to help you it's good if they're
legitimately just peaceful and and i
okay i don't care same
like wouldn't you be down to just live
and co-exist i mean it's a it's a it's a
mind you know what's up
if they're living peacefully and like
bringing technology and you know
whatever it's just because like the
american colonists when they came in the
native americans they were totally
peaceful i mean i don't know if they
were totally people they're very
peaceful to a lot of them no they
weren't thanks for helping us live
throughout the winter learning how to
grow corn stop not all of them i'm not
saying all of them no the story you're
talking about also does not end well
well there were people like cortez in
mexico was very peaceful at first with
the aztecs okay he said the aztecs it
was cortez was so much there at first
and in the incans the um
who was it pizarro i think went down
with the incas they loved him they
accepted him he went he befriended the
emperor and then they
they captured him and executed basically
they took him prisoner yeah everybody
just fights so the aliens came and they
were like yeah we can help you let's put
us in the white house would you here's
here's here's oh but here's here's the
issue i have with that
like you think they're going to be
people
they're like let's just say aliens show
up and there's a gigantic ship and it's
filled with uh it's filled with water
and the aliens are gigantic fleshy sacks
with no eyes or ears or mouths
and they consume by sucking water in
like filters but they're also they also
have big brains we won't even there's no
communication with them
also we need water so if they suck up
all the water we're dead no they filter
the water like like like you know a
filter humans are pretty xenophobic i
think the humans would eradicate them
every every species is xenophobic well
this is why i said to you it would never
happen that they'd be peaceful because
if they made the effort to come here
there'd be a reason for it i think
they'd start taking stuff right my idea
i want to do a short film where an alien
ship comes down over new york and then
everyone's like wow aliens and then you
know someone's they they go up onto the
skyscraper and they look and they're
like
you know come make contact and then all
of a sudden a gigantic laser beam just
slices a building in half
and then attracts and then it just falls
and a tractor being grabs it and strips
rips all the copper and metal wiring out
and the rest just crumbles and falls to
the ground crushing people then a bunch
of ships come down and start mowing down
buildings and ripping out the metals and
then people are like oh no they're
attacking us
and then it switches the perspective of
the aliens and it's just some fat
lumberjack alien going we got a big crop
here get the critters out of there and
then we'll just strip the the copper out
bring it back to the ship like we don't
go there and negotiate with squirrels
you know we don't we don't go into the
fields of wheat and negotiate with the
with the field mice and the bunnies we
don't care we just wipe a little look at
the history of human beings man anytime
a group of people has moved from one
area to another
it always ends the same way yeah it's uh
whoever whoever has the power to sustain
their their their group their tribe 100
so you know if that's life as we see it
on earth and it's indicative of most
life like invasive life uh invasive
light organisms take the opportunity to
invade when they can but natural
predators curtail them why would any
alien race coming to earth be any
different it's possible they could be we
just have no reason to believe that
based on life on yes you hear that
aliens you would be fools to come here
first send us a message so that we can
chat consider before you arrive the
difference is there's no intelligent
life we've been able to uh
technologically advance intelligence
species that we've been able to to work
with but take a look at how we deal with
whales right whales are intelligent very
intelligent and we just shoot them and
kill them i just you know i read a story
about whales that they're actually land
mammals that went back into the ocean
they evolved on land and then at some
point back in uh-huh freaking wild yeah
that's why they're mammals underwater
that's my derail for the day all right
let's talk about uh where this could
potentially go then instead of the world
falling apart it could be gutted trump
reportedly plans to purge the deep state
if he wins next election will use
executive order to strip employment
protections that's about it they're
saying up to 50 000 employees could be
fired uh i'm voting for trump that's it
that's all
you you you say that to me good sir and
i'm like okay i'll vote for you
there's a lot trump could do wrong at
this point i'd still vote come on baby
take me back i won't hit you again come
on no way he said he was gonna do it the
first time not like this trump actually
did implement executive order schedule f
and then biden reversed it so trump
began the process of trying to fire
these guys these these bureaucrat
administrative state people have have
protections but i'll tell you this it
doesn't matter
joe biden is spitting on us and beating
us over the head and my worst case
scenario is like this guy's promising to
do better it's already bad plus under
trump the economy was good
i'll take it
what else what about your desantis push
see that's what i was saying i said i
don't think desantis would fire
everybody like trump would and then all
of a sudden we get a report that trump
wants to fire everybody there we go do
you think trump's listening to you do
you think that's what the that's what
happened yeah i said trump fire
everybody and then trump was like i
think i'm going to fire everybody yeah
what if the sansa said he's going to
fire everybody as well would you vote
for him
well maybe the thing is
that is big
and if desantis said he was going to go
in and fire everybody the exact same way
that's a huge advantage
i don't know though i think trump's got
a bone to pick right i think what really
makes me believe trump would do it is he
wants revenge
that's it desantis would probably try to
negotiate and summer things down and
then get taken advantage of because
that's what trump tried doing he's like
i'm gonna drain the swamp he gets in and
says okay okay we'll we'll bring bolton
and fine
got knifed in the back for that one
now i think trump
they they really really went after him i
think he wants revenge for russiagate
so
it's that it is his anger over
russiagate and and being impeached for
ukraine gate where i think he's going to
go and it should be like you're fired
you're fired you're fired
ronda sanchez doesn't need revenge but
then what after like if he fires
everyone is going to be trusted like can
we can we believe that he's going to
install well what kind of matters after
that like because that's what i was
going to say do you really want a guy
who's angry and wants revenge as
president united states i don't mind
anymore but like if he cleans house in
the first year
what happens after that how do we know
that he's got less government yeah but
like how do we know he's not going to be
advised we'll just just let this guy
come in and then it's kind of all going
to go back how do we know that he's
going to be able to reinstall something
because i think rock bottom exists
and i think what we've looked at with
the uniparty over the past several
decades is so far down we've hit mantle
mm-hmm no rock bottom would be like
fallout we don't that's fallout like the
fallout universe the video game after
it's like post nuclear no i'm i'm
talking about
with with the corruption of our
government
when marjorie taylor green told us that
there's like two people sitting in the
house and then they're just like yay
passed next bill
what was that
is that a yes whatever passed did you
know that that's what they do
congress doesn't even go in to vote
it is so broken at this point okay
you're fired get rid of all of it and
then it's like but but but then we'll
have no government i'm like
okay
you have not you've not made a negative
point yet that's a net positive in my
opinion considering how bad it's been
now there's there's the potential that
donald trump appoints a bunch of
authoritarian fascists it's not going to
happen either donald trump was going to
bring in people like peter navarro and
cash patel who we've already seen who
are actually pretty good and so it's
like okay he guts
they're saying that they don't have to
gut 50 000 people just enough to where
people stop
being corrupt because they know they'll
get purge it'll straighten things out
all right well i'll take whatever i can
get the system's already broken right
someone already stole my tv
i don't got a tv anymore donald trump
says
we're gonna go in and we're gonna we're
gonna arrest all these people and get
them out of there and we're gonna deal
with the police department like oh
whatever my stuff's all gone do it do
something i think the system's always
been kind of janky like put together by
duct tape and string and then the
american constitution was pretty cool
and it makes it run like the engine is
turning everything's okay it's pumping
out a lot of carbon but you know it's
functioning even though it's held
together by duct tape and if you don't
constantly like keep patching it up it's
just gonna break and then fall on the
ground so we're in that stage of like
why is it shaking so fast i don't know i
don't want to touch it i'm gonna get
killed if i get near it no it's we got
to do something about this you know
maybe maybe the transmission is a little
bit old on this old rickety country and
you got to take it apart clean it out
and reconstruct it you know what i mean
just put it back in order to do that you
got to stop the machine for a little
while and fire everybody would be
fantastic isn't that what the work think
that this country needs to just be
broken apart and start again no they
think you need to take the transmission
out shout out to a million pieces and
then try and put some and build a new
one or put nothing in place they think
this machine is producing carbon it
needs to be pulled out and then we'll be
great and you're like you need the
machine
so we have a machine that works works
really really well it's a brilliant
system of government we just need to get
rid of the gunk that's stuck in it you
know what i mean just pull it out and
throw in the trash they want to just
shatter the machine
they have no replacement i i what i see
is that trump another trump
term
brings this whole thing that we've been
talking about today
ten levels further you're getting closer
to civil war
much much closer
they've already written articles saying
ron desantis is worse than trump
numerous they will of course they will
so if the argument is that trump winning
escalates it
well they're claiming random sentences
is worse than trump so wouldn't that
escalate one article doesn't mean they
all believe it's not one article
numerous articles from numerous
personalities all coming out in lockstep
knowing over the past several months
they saying ron desantis is even worse
than trump ron desantis is he's got the
the sly slick tongue which makes him
even more dangerous
like they said trump was worse than
hitler how many times
if that's the escalation they have trump
is bad they're trying to claim
descendants is worse and they've been
doing it for months
if if descendants wins
it's the same thing it's it's it's not
changing we need we need to just have
someone get in and fire these people and
shut it down
that's not that's not good there's no
there's no
so what's the alternative
let the corrupt gut the machine and sink
the ship term limits for administrative
staff and congress people
uh convention of states but perhaps yes
that's what they're trying to do
convention of states amendment for term
limits on the deep state
i i just i don't see how any of these
things stop the escalation a convention
of states would be the same thing as
trump getting elected if we could get
the governors together and actually be
able to convene on a regular basis
enough of us
government governance we could take
control and solve a lot of issues i
think i think it's mostly a cultural
thing anyways like we all know politics
is downstream of culture it won't change
until the culture changes the culture it
can't be changed because there's two
distinct
fortified cultures sure but this is not
the first time in history that's been
the case
well i mean typically throughout history
when you have two distinct world views
they don't just come together and shake
hands sure they
wipe the other side out so right now we
have one culture that thinks children
should get sex change surgery and one
side that thinks they shouldn't
i think i don't think there's not really
a compromise there you have one side
that that thinks there should be
abortion post viability elective
abortion post viability and one side
that doesn't and there's no compromise
and there's that's it there's none
i don't i don't see how you convince
when when right now uh you've got
twitter and reddit saying you can't call
people groomers and they're actually
you've actually people grooming children
you've got a government administration
official saying we should give sex
change surgery to children
well dude but they call it affirmation
guys you know i agree with you and all
of this right you know that uh my
concern is again just speaking as an
outsider i don't comment on american
politics in the sense that i don't live
here i don't pay taxes here it's your
country you deal with with it what you
want
but the conversation i'm hearing here
and with a lot of other people that i
meet
is
like this conversation takes you to a
point of no return
but but there's there's no this is what
i'm hearing right this is why i've been
saying i think civil war is inevitable
because there is no circumstance let me
look do you like the nhs you're from the
uk right yeah do you like it's called
the nhs right it is do you like it
it's hard to it's a hard question to
answer some of it is good some of it's
terrible um do you prefer it like to
what to a private system like we have in
the united states
well i've never experienced the american
system so i don't really know would you
give it up
the nhs like if someone came in and said
we want to abolish it outright would you
agree to that depends what they put in
we don't have a plan we want to get rid
of it
no
you wouldn't do that no because i want
to i will come on compromise with me
though like right
how about we get rid of it and then
we'll negotiate on what the
no
let's talk about what you're proposing
instead my proposal is to gut that
system because it's evil and wrong and
replace it with well we'll figure that
out when it comes to it i'm not
interested so it doesn't matter what
you're interested in because we're going
to take it anyway and if you don't
listen we're going to throw a brick
through your window that's that's the
point being made right now in the united
states
so when someone comes out and says
we should be able to terminate a a
viable baby at eight months if if we
want to or not
there's literally no compromise but that
isn't the law right so there is a
compromise it is in i think seven states
and dc yes and then you have i think was
it how many states have totally banned
abortion at six well there's a lot of
block to it because of the judicial
challenges but i think it's six in total
so we're getting to that point there is
it's
no but they're not trying to mandate
that at the federal level you can live
in a state where that isn't the case
right the democrats are trying to
mandate the federal level that you can
abort a baby post a viability up to nine
months yes that's what roe v wade did
for us right he made it a felony but
roe v wade made it so you couldn't ban
abortion pre-viability so uh it was
initially a trimester standard changed
to a viability standard democrats tried
codifying a bill that would allow for
elect
i shouldn't say elective abortion in the
instance of health of the mother up to
nine months but there's there's a trick
there
abortion would mean uh it said post it
said
uh it would allow for abortion of a
viable fetus in the instance of health
of the mother and so the issue there is
if the fetus is viable it can survive
outside the mother why kill it
why legalize the killing of it so
they're like if ma'am if you keep this
baby for another week you'll die so
we're gonna kill the baby
we could deliver it we could do a c
second nah we're gonna kill it
so the question is okay maybe maybe
there's a moral argument to why they
wanted to do that they don't have one
they don't give me one i've asked
numerous progressives they don't post it
online why they want to do it and so the
only thing i can say is they're trying
to find a workaround to abort viable
like to kill viable babies
but you have a system in place that
prevents that from being the federal law
right
it could be unless the democrats tried
to make it federal law of course but
you've got to be able to co-exist with
people with whom you disagree in the
same society
so the issue is that i'm saying the
disagreements are untenable there's no
compromise there's no circumstance where
well so so the compromise was the
overturning of roe v wade conservatives
saying how about your state can do what
you want our state can do what we want
the problem there is that's one more
domino being knocked over towards a
civil war because the scenario i've
presented is what happens when a man and
a woman hook up woman gets pregnant and
then eight months later she says you
know what this guy is not right for me
i'm going to go terminate the baby in
texas it would be illegal for her to do
so and i think it may be oklahoma where
they have or might be like idaho or
something i'm not sure which one they
have they have an abortion trafficking
law meaning if you aid or traffic in
abortion abortifications or tools or or
helping someone get abortion it's a
crime
how will texas deal with the fact that
there's a man saying she kidnapped my
baby at eight months gestation who's
viable and could survive if we just
deliver instead of killing it i'll take
it she can leave and she goes no that
would tie me to you i'm gonna go kill it
instead
what happens
when she flees to colorado for an
eight-month elective abortion which she
can get and the father in texas says
texas government please help she's
kidnapped my son
i don't see a solution there
i mean
the way i see it is to try trying to
explain it to pro-choice people would be
imagine a woman kidnapped a baby the day
it was born and then went to a state
where they were going to let her chop
its head off
they'd be like but it's a baby it's like
right right the conservative pro-life
people view it the exact same way when
it's in the womb at eight months versus
when it's out of the women agents
so what do you do
when there's no federal intervention and
the states are forced to decide how do
we save that child from execution does
texas invade colorado or do they tell
the guy sorry she escaped the state no i
think what might happen is colorado
would dema sorry texas would demand
colorado extradite colorado would refuse
then texas would say
we're not going to allow people to cross
we're setting up a checkpoint now to
make sure that people can't do this ever
again and then you'd see state borders
popping up and then you'd probably see
vigilantism the dad who doesn't want a
son killed would probably get a posse
together who knows that's the escalation
without federal intervention and there
isn't any anymore so the compromise was
we don't like abortion but we'll let you
do it but now you have people fleeing to
go do it and it's going to create more
tension
that makes sense my point is you're
going to have to work this out man you
just die
that's that's the situation or see a lot
of people talk about civil war you've
never lived through civil war
you don't you don't want it
and that's why the veterans are the ones
who are like please stop right we've
seen conflict and so that that's what my
take on certainly in the uk is like yes
the work have gone crazy
the progressives have gone crazy and
some of the response on the right
bothers me too there's got to be a way
through okay um
compromise
what level of child sex change are you
okay with
um
i mean you're picking on a very specific
issue like we can talk about it for half
an hour there's probably some kind of
compromise for example i employ several
people who have gender dysphoria right
if they want to transition
at the age of 16 with parental consent
do i i don't even know 16 17 18 where
should that line be right well that
we're talking about you know seven year
olds no
well children can't consent well they're
transphobic because this is what they're
doing this is what they're doing in the
united states
and the government came out and told
parents to do it and biden did the same
well see here's the thing right we had a
guy on from the tavistock clinic in the
uk on my show on trigonometry he was
basically a whistleblower saying what
all what was happening in this clinic
well guess what the arguments that
people were making about that exposing
what was happening now the situation is
being rode back laws are being changed
people are actually getting uh to a
healthier position on that issue and i
think we're making progress right so i
do think
shining a light on some of the stuff
will help over time but if you want an
instant solution yeah you're not going
to get it
so i i don't i'm not saying there's an
instant solution i'm saying you go to
someone and tell them something very
simple like hey i don't think children
can consent to this stuff i don't think
they know and they call you a transphobe
big and try to get you banned i've been
there trust me uh it was mario lopez who
said three-year-olds don't know if
they're transgender and he was forced to
issue an apology
the on this front it has only been
expanding in in the direction towards
child sex changes not only not in the uk
we're making progress right but this is
what i'm saying you you're not going to
get straight to where you want to go
right away but we are seeing people
winning cases in court saying that for
example the belief i don't know if you
followed the my start for starter case
uh it was a case in the uk where
basically she was i think fired or
denied the promotion because she said
that trans women aren't women or women
oh right yeah something like that right
and the court actually found in favor of
her and it's now a protected
philosophical belief or whatever so you
can make progress by
what we're doing here which is having a
conversation exposing certain things to
the light and that is the way you do it
unless you want civil war unless you
want people to die in the hundreds of
thousands no of course not i don't think
you do this and that's why i'm saying
the focus should be on how do you get to
a better place
sorry i was gonna ask um with boris
johnson resigning how are the other
political parties in the uk reacting to
that it's very hard for me to imagine
you know we don't if a president
resigned in the u.s and then whatever
party was in power got to just pick a
new one it it's hard for me to imagine
americans going through that system well
wouldn't the vice president become vice
president would become but for you boris
johnson stepped down yeah and you guys
just get to pick well we're a
parliamentary system we don't elect a
prime minister we're like we like the
pond but it's interesting we have a
problem in the uk now because what
happened was boris johnson resigns there
is uh the way that the elections happen
is the mps the members of parliament
pick the two top nominees and then
members of the party pick from out of
those two right and what they did of
course they had a great candidate who
was super popular with the membership
no no no she's very unpopular with a
membership uh kemi badanok uh obeyed
enoch she is incredible on all the stuff
that we're talking about the trans stuff
the cultural stuff brilliant and so of
course they made sure that she didn't
yeah she never polled in even in the top
four she never got into the final even
though with the membership she would
have been a hundred percent the winner
and she would have been prime minister
they they forced to not so
we've got big problems tim i'm not
disagreeing with you so to go back to
your point about you know having a
discussion and compromising
we've uh since the start of the show
politely invited people on the left to
come and hang out as a vibe we've all
been through this i get it right they
don't they don't and the other issue is
we've also set back and let them
literally murder people
without without accountability
figuratively murdered people
they just got released
what do you mean what like they would
catch and release these people right i'm
saying this but there's been there's
been murders without accountability
there's been violence to that
accountability there was uh two billion
dollars in capped damage in the summer
of love the rights there was the 529
insurrection and then you know with all
due respect you're here saying well we
need to have a conversation and
compromise i'm like i've never used the
word compromise by the way okay sorry
all right no one is fun but we have a
conversation right 100 like okay well
dude
i'm sitting here minding my own business
i get out of the cities i say please
just leave me alone over and over and
over again and then i'm told well if you
don't talk to these people and what's to
talk about at this point i retreated and
they're still burning down throwing
bricks through windows and trying to
assassinate people i agree that's
completely wrong but
there's no conversation with people who
are defending you don't have to have the
conversation with them here's what i'm
saying right
the society is made up of about seven
percent of people who are progressive
crazy blah blah blah right and there's a
small bunch of people on the other side
on the other extreme who are crazy
equally
everybody else actually is in the middle
now it depends country by country what
that middle looks like i don't know you
tell me what that the how big that is in
the u.s
in the uk i'd reckon that's 80 85
those people are the vast overwhelming
silent majority right and i think
they're coming over to our side with
every single one of these instances that
you're talking about
and to me i don't want to talk to the
crazies on either side i'm interested
how do we get the sensible people in the
middle to see sense to stop legislating
for all this crap that we've got going
on and actually have policies that make
sense for the majority of the people in
this country because the majority of
people in any country are not crazy and
this is why
we may be seeing a red tsunami in
november
that uh latinos for instance in the rio
grande valley they're all but this is
the the election of trump this is the
election of trump supporters and and uh
trump republicans his endorsements what
do you know what his ratio is on
endorsements
trump it's like 110 yeah it's some crazy
number i don't know what off the top so
what's happened is donald trump is a
moderate he's just bombastic his
policies were that of like uh
late 90s 2000s dem new york democrat now
it's considered conservative he unfurled
a rainbow flag at the i think it was the
rnc or something he's the first
president u.s history to support gay
marriage before being president even
hillary clinton didn't support it in
2016. so you get this moderate to be
president and he woke up a bunch of
regular people the neocons hated it he
was moderate in his policies in most of
them he wasn't moderate in his behavior
then that's what that's what triggers
them you know exactly right and so
people who are based on whose decisions
are making is based on emotion they
couldn't stand what trump was no but the
people who are flocking to him they're
flocking to him because he's saying he's
going to nuke the gov he's going to fire
all these people he's going to purge the
system and people are sick of the broken
system and what's what's fascinating is
the democratic party is becoming
wealthier and more white
and they are the second most pressing
issue for democrats is political
extremism that's why democrats are
screaming abortion and january 6th but
regular people don't care about that
stuff right so this is why i think their
their the democrats providing funding to
trump endorsed candidates is a
ridiculous mistake and what's going to
end up happening is
when donald trump invariably
wins
do you think he's going to win i i well
we're an eternity away but i don't see
how the democrats could beat trump at
this point
so look we got two years
joe biden's aggregate approval
record low has has gone lower than
trump's lowest so right now objectively
biden is hated by more hated more by
america than trump ever was
you put trump up against that and he's
gonna be like hey i got mean tweets best
numbers of our lives so that's what jim
cramer said remember that dollar 84 for
gasoline remember that was like 213
national average but we saw it go down
to like 150 in some areas
yeah people at this point are going to
be like don't take a ham sandwich over
the democrats but what do you think
happens with the the the wealthy elites
in the democratic party who know they're
facing probably criminal investigation
and prosecution like hunter biden he
currently is well this is this was my
point is i i'm worried first of all that
if trump does get elected he's not going
to get a lot done because they just
won't let him
right that's what happened with the
first term well that's my point so why
would it be easier with the second term
post january 6 well they think this was
this was unleashed right so that's the
thing but look come back to my point
which i think is actually you tell me
how true it is because i don't know that
much about the united states i don't
live here right but i do believe there's
a sensible majority of people in the
middle who are there to be won over by
either side either side
as long as they start talking sense on a
lot of these issues right i think and in
the uk that's what happened that's what
happened it depends on the data
the data that you look at right now i
think the latest data i saw in in
factioning it's it's a bell curve so
it's actually not 80 percent are in the
middle it's
30 you know 20 to 30 are in the actual
middle and then you have left leaning
right leaning then you have left right
then you have hard left hard right
what we saw with pew was that the
sideliners the regular people are
actually you know i think it was like 15
to 20 percent and they're center right
so like
it's obvious when you look at what the
left is
that regular people would be center
right relative to them because you need
you need a baseline for what the left is
and clearly the regular people aren't
there um
but i think these people for the most
part still aren't
wanting to to vote outside of the
democrats or vote for anything that we
saw this in 2018 when i think it was 31
moderate democrats got elected in trump
districts
because they promised to actually
entertain real issues and then they went
for impeachment and they just became
culture warriors and it was like
abandoning regular people but
i don't know
if these people uh
i'll put it this way
i don't know i don't know how big the
middle is if there even is one what we
saw from twitter trends was i hyped the
middle was flattened out and spread far
left what we saw from pew research was
that the middle out that the middle has
been flattened and now spread the the
the mod the middle of the left is far
left in the middle of the right is a
little bit more right than it used to be
but there's no there's it's a valley in
the middle now well i mean on twitch
twitch no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no i'm talking
about pew registration yeah yeah i think
it's a valley not not a bell curve yeah
i hear you maybe this is the way in
which our countries are different but i
i do think that um
one of the reasons people on the center
left would never vote republican in the
conception of it as it has been is
because of the way that trump was they
they may well vote for someone who's a
little bit more not sensible necessarily
in terms of policy but sensible in terms
of the way that they comport themselves
this might be because you know that
triggers the hell out of them well this
is why maybe desantis that's my point
but that's my point we we need to fire
the administrative state it is the
biggest threat to this country in my
opinion it is it is it is
the swamp does not convey the slime
and and putrescence of the corruption in
this country i don't think you can fire
them though i agree that it's a problem
for sure but if you go up and you're
like i want all 100 out 10 000 of you to
be fired tomorrow they're like well we
control all the spy networks and all the
sub you know military machines like you
really want us to you're really going to
try and get us dude we're not you one
guy we're not talking about that we're
talking about civil servants we're
talking about people who work in
administrative offices they run the cia
those are the people that run the their
their shadow government basically trump
wants to appoint a new head of the cia
and fbi that's different
from the the general civil servants the
two million of which operate in all
facets of government and yes trump's
attempt was to schedule f them so they
would be fired so my point is rather
than be like you're all done tomorrow be
like you've got term limits now you've
got two more years to finish out your
turn
well the idea would be to fire the
people who are redundant and replace
them
wait if they're redundant you wouldn't
replace them all right fire fire the
people who are unnecessary i'm open to
that but we should cycle them out almost
all in two years rather than coming to
be like tomorrow
i don't think he would really all in one
day be like everyone go but i think it
would be in quick success that's why i
gave like i was like saying if he can do
it in one his first year let's say trump
gets reelected all of 2024 he's cleaning
house you know it's not like
it's all over one day it's not like when
they replace the white house but very
over the course of 12 months he cleans
out everyone who needs to be gone
my question is
who are who is filling in the ranks even
if he downsizes the government who is
coming in to replace them you might not
need to replace them as as you know as
ian pointed out if they're redundant or
unnecessary and then would we pay as
taxpayers just pay their their
retirement packages just basically give
them like a bail like a bailout and send
them i think they should get
unemployment go find another job
unemployment yeah like anybody else in
this country i am concerned with what
you're saying hannah claire about who's
coming in next because and i don't want
to be too hard on trump but one of the
things i i really bothered me about
trump was the way he handled covid and
how he just handed power to fauci and
was like this unelected body can now
control the whims of the people and make
decision i'm like i didn't elect fauci i
don't i didn't i don't want fauci in
this medical industry deciding what i
have to do with my daily life that's
great medical tyranny is as dangerous as
banking tyranny or his martial tyranny
in a lot of ways what bothers me more
about it is who is attracted to that
kind of bureaucratic federal position i
mean in some ways you're not running for
office you're getting appointed and
maybe you lead a department and you
oversee the budget and you get to sign
the paperwork that can really make a
tremendous difference in people's lives
i mean i just
i have such skepticism for the way
government works it's not that i don't
think we should continue to fight to
make the system work or fix it where
it's wrong but like i just don't know
who is applying for these jobs even if
trump is in office i i
that kind of person or the historically
those people are
uh
i don't know
do you know about the war game they did
the boston globe reported on in 2020. it
was like john podesta hillary clinton
campaign some neocons
they effectively played what was d and d
this is really funny we should totally
do this by the way
they they did a dungeon of dragons on
the on the on the 2020 election
and so they were like okay john podesta
you're going to play trump's campaign
and so and so you're this campaign and
then they took turns deciding what they
would do rolling die to see what would
happen yeah it was crazy i think that's
what they did with yeah like it was like
dnd yeah we should totally do it and
film it'll be so fun awesome and uh uh i
believe it was in in this war game i
remember who it was it might have been
podesta
they they they said that the west coast
should secede from the union if donald
trump wins another term
should or would should they they were
trying to encourage washington oregon
and california to secede
so i i think about stuff like that and
i'm like why even
literally entertain that as like they
thought that would happen is that what
they thought would happen so it was like
i i i don't know exactly who was the one
who suggested i don't think it was
podesta but someone in the game suggests
it's a session so you know what i'm
looking at is
when
i've been reading a lot about the first
civil war
for instance texas apparently joined the
confederacy out of uh
it was a geographic necessity they
needed a trade partner and they were
blocked off from the rest of the union
they're like we don't know what else we
would do i guess
maryland wanted to join uh there was the
sentiment in maryland was to join the
south
but
they just couldn't do it for a lot of
reasons one was that the union went in
and arrested 31 reps in the state who
supported secession and the rest were
like we'll do whatever you say man and
then lincoln suspended happiest corpus
in the corridor from dc through maryland
up to pennsylvania so they can arrest
whoever they want without charge or
trial really crazy stuff
people understand the depth of what
happened with the civil war they assume
it was like all these states got
together high-fived each other and said
we're not the confederacy when would
actually happen was a small handful
seceded and that was the end of it then
lincoln gets elected then lincoln gets
inaugurated he was elected his election
resulted in this he's immediately says
session is illegitimate and we're coming
for you
the battle at fort sumter starts then
several other states were like yo this
is getting crazy we're with the other
guys on this one you're a tyrant
so
it could be
that texas bans abortion and everyone
says well this is crazy colorado has
unrestricted that scenario pointed out
earlier occurs and everyone's like it's
just two states it's just two states
and then another state says we're
cutting off all trade line supplies and
contracting if you are imagine this in
texas they say
any business that operates in texas is
no longer allowed to operate out of
colorado we will not allow transactions
to the state to any banking institution
in the state because they kidnapped
children and murdered them things like
that might start happening then you
might get
you know the federal government coming
in and pressuring texas and texas saying
you're you're pressing up on our laws
then all of a sudden oklahoma is like yo
this is crazy what are you doing in
texas and then goes to provide a to
texas one by one you'll see dominoes
falling down no i hear what you're
saying and this is why we're having this
conversation because what i'm saying is
people in positions like yours and mine
who are having conversations about these
issues i think the way we've got to look
at it is what is the outcome that we're
trying to achieve or the outcome that
we're at least trying to prevent right
now if we accept that civil war is bad
do we accept that it's terrible right
worse than bad people understand one of
the bloodiest wars in history of course
and he would be way worse now than it
has been at any time in history before
the the i'll just i'll just stress this
man
it is especially with antifa these
people have never seen grievous injury
i sw that you know uh
i i will say trigger warning for for
people listening because i know there
are people who have dealt with real
trauma and i mean this like a real
trigger not some stupid you know oh it's
offensive word no i've seen people whose
legs have been turned into ground chuck
and the feeling you get when you see
that kind of stuff or the feeling you
get when i when i saw when i saw the
first time i saw a dead person being
carted away from me in a conflict
i it's a it's a feeling that i never
felt before and i was uh i was like 27
years old and it was weird 27 years old
and i was like this is an emotion i've
never experienced now i imagine back in
the day it's an emotion people
experienced quite a bit because people
died you know in front of them and there
was war and we grew up in this safety
bubble so i tell you when these antifa
people actually see it in front of them
when they start to see that it's going
to change it's going to it's going to
twist their brains in ways they did not
expect the feeling they get but it may
make many of them more radical 100 so
that's what i'm saying is we got to work
back from that civil war bad very very
bad right so how do you avoid it well
the way you avoid it is you find a
democratic solution by targeting the
people in the middle who are actually
quite fed up they're quite fed up of all
this crap that's going on uh they're
quite afraid they're worried about
speaking their mind and we give them
permission to do that we make it okay we
challenge some of the legal changes that
are being made this is the process we're
starting very slowly some people
disagree with me even in the uk where i
come from right but
we are making some slow progress and i
think that's the way you do it you
target that middle you bring them on
board and then you avoid the terrible
thing that we'd all like to avoid i do
agree i agree with the strategy and it i
i you know some people say it's
pessimistic when i'm like i think it may
be inevitable or the dominoes are
falling over and that seems to be the
outcome or
we're in some kind of civil war as it is
fifth generational warfare
but
it may be pessimistic but at timcats.com
we're certainly trying to do that right
yeah so
when we were starting uh when we were
expanding the company
i took a look at a bunch of what other
companies had done and you look at every
single commentary and podcasting network
and what do they do they load up on
commentators and get a big roster of
commentators who all have similar
opinions
that's not what we did because my goal
isn't just to make money my goal is to
affect change so the first thing we did
i think the first show we launched was
sales from the inverted world which is
paranormal true crime mystery with shane
cashman because i said what we want to
do is we want uh we want to create a
space
where people who are hearing nothing but
this stuff can kind of chill out with
fun entertainment so we're not just
creating a hyper-polarized commentary
space right we launched cass castle
comedy and silliness we launched pop
culture crisis conversations about
celebrities and gossip so that it's a
it's a it's an eclectic space so people
who are worried about this stuff that
we're talking about they'll have a space
to actually talk about normal things and
the culture we want to build excludes
the woken sanity and antifa they won't
be a part of the world that we're trying
to create so what what i'm hoping to do
is
we're running ads right now we just
launched one simple ad so far as a trial
run for tales from the inverted world
we saw tremendous uh tremendous um
results among 18 to 24 year old men and
65 and up women
so 18 to 24 year old men
we get 18 to 54 year old men on this
show really really well with the spike
being i think 25 to 34. 18 to 24 is low
so getting a big response on tails from
the inverted world is huge and 65 year
old women not to mention women across
the board really responded well in the
ads the reason this is good is i want
people to come to tim cast i want them
to see these stories and be pulled away
from disney and netflix and hulu and the
weird woke stuff and then just watch pop
culture crisis in cass castle and the
other shows we're going to launch comedy
specials
i don't want to to to bring them into a
space that is dominated by conservatives
or even libertarians screaming the end
of an eye
it is bad enough that that's what we're
essentially doing so we want to create a
space that slowly starts carving out
something that's more relaxing i love it
man i think that's great and we are
doing that this is the same thing with
trigonometry we've got big plans because
culture is at the core of this right
comedy humor music entertainment that's
the way you do it uh you can scream
about politics all day long and you can
change some things but culture that's
where you get masses of people who are
not political but who do you know they
feel like they can't say what they think
at work or they've got some kind of
other issue going on and they don't want
to be a a sort of culture warrior or in
this space uh i think comedy is a big
part of it that's why we do our raw
shows and we make fun of everybody left
and right because that's how i think you
get people to that from that middle to
that middle and i think it's really
great that you're doing that we're gonna
try that i mean you look at you know
daily wire obviously very different to
what we do but um you know they're
they're making movies yep right they get
it this is how you do it man the daily
wire is not making conservative movies
right exactly i don't want to watch a
conservative movie i don't want to watch
it i just want to watch a movie and
relax and have a good time that's what i
want exactly and i don't want to hear
about 72 genders while i'm at it just
leave that out show me the movie i'll
enjoy it and i think that's the way man
so i'm really glad we had this
conversation actually because i think
this is the way we get to a healthier
place by trying to get to a healthier
place because i hear you i wake up
sometimes and i'm like holy [ __ ] this is
going down the toilet fast yeah but the
only thing you and i can do all of us in
this room can do is try to make it a
little bit better one step at a time the
way i see it is uh building an ark and
uh maybe there won't be a great flood
but we'll have this big really cool
community space that people can come
hang out in if the if if the end result
is the world falls apart and everyone's
fighting well timcats.com will still be
producing a plethora of content from a
variety of subjects we are going to be
launching more political shows of like
slightly different political persuasions
but still similarly in the libertarian
kind of space
but i don't want to just do a bunch of
shows about politics like we have a show
we talk about politics we want to do
other stuff we want people to be able to
just get it
i want people to say
disney plus get well go broke i don't
like this i'm going to give my money to
timcast.com it's 100 man now
for both the daily wires is light years
ahead of us for sure they have like
nearly a million subs we're nowhere near
nowhere near that and they've got um
multiple commentators they've got i
think five movies now uh some shows are
coming out they announced chip chiller
their kids show i'm i'm deeply jealous
of everything that they're doing but you
know we're working on ours and and we
focus on what we're doing
we
daily wire is going to get their way
before us for sure but i'm just saying
this
there are people who who become members
because they believe in the mission
but that's not enough what we need to do
is just have the better show we need to
get a show we need to get to the point
where the comedy is special and then
people are like
they they go into work one day and
they're like oh did you watch that news
have you seen the showcase castle i've
been watching this hilarious show on
teamcast.com like no what is that it's
like oh you it's like it's like a show
you know it's comedy it's funny it's
that's what we want to get to so then
people are like eh disney plus is boring
that's the way that is 100 away and you
know what happened to to the mainstream
of the comedy industry in the uk right
what happened was they had these great
shows that everybody watched 15 years
ago mock the week live of the apollo
these were shows that everybody watched
everybody wanted to be on as a comic and
within about 10 15 years they've really
ruined them i think from what i hear
down the group of mine they're getting
they're going to be not renewed and it's
happened to other shows as well because
here's how you do it it's very simple
right you stop employing people based on
merit you start employing people based
on their
various characteristics and you make bad
stuff and then you make bad content yeah
and then people come along and go hey
well we've got the internet we've got
the technology we've got the talent the
skills the comedic experience whatever
we'll write our own thing we'll make our
own thing that's the solution here man
what happened with doctor who i remember
when uh they
they
brought in the woman to be the first
female doctor and then what i had heard
was that the show basically became magic
school bus so like instead of instead of
an episode where they go to i remember
the one episode i really remember fondly
was when the robots had killed everybody
and the smiles do you watch doctor who i
don't there's an episode where they go
to a planet and then it was um peter
capaldi i think was the was the doctor
at the time the older guy
is that his name i don't know but uh the
robots all had smiley faces and the
robots killed anybody who was sad to
stop sadness from spreading
and that was like an interesting plot
and then what i heard with uh when they
when they brought in the woman the plot
lines were like going to india to talk
about partition and like colonialism and
it was like okay
you know i want to see a dragon fight a
time wizard not learn a history lesson
right if you want to make magic school
bus and so i don't know exactly what
happened with it but i i i heard it like
it wasn't doing well people didn't want
to watch it i'll tell you how bad it got
so i was i used to write on the
equivalent of like jimmy kimmel or
whatever it was called the mash report
in the uk and
i would watch the program only when i
was involved in it and i would only tend
to watch like five minutes because the
rest of it was just this like preaching
no jokes just preaching
uh there were some good bits there was a
few comics it was good but and that's
how that so to me when i see that i
think that's great let them destroy this
thing that they spent decades building
and let us come in and build something
better that's that's that's where that's
the way man that's what i do i only
listen when tim reads my articles
exactly no i'm just kidding but the
youngest generation of i think americans
i don't know if the poll was done
globally they said if they had if they
could only have one social media
platform they'd have youtube of course
and youtube i mean you you are probably
a great example of this has so many
different creators it's
you know if you are interested in
something any niche thing out there you
can find it i mean tick tock has really
evolved into this too but
this was this poll was done i think in
2017 and they all pick youtube they
watch youtube more than they watch
television and again that is specific
power to creators to be able to reach an
audience that is really interested in
what they have
real quick there's something interesting
too that i want to mention that we
talked about earlier today because we've
we've heavily focused on treating
timcast like a subscription service
the goal is to make contact with content
that's sustainable
and some people have pointed out we
could put the uh our episodes on other
platforms instead of requiring a
membership you could just buy the
episode for a couple bucks or something
i was like that's actually a really good
idea so there's still a way for some of
our content to to be on these big
platforms in a way that they're
supported but i will i will add to that
idea too because people mentioned it
like hey can you make the tim cast
uncensored segments you know available
for one-off purchase and it's like we
don't we don't have the tech on the
website we could build that and we can't
do it on youtube because youtube would
ban us
so what we're trying to do with youtube
is effectively be a pipeline where
someone on youtube will see us they can
come to the website and get unfiltered
uncensored content bingo and this is
what i think is happening in the in the
media online space is it's kind of like
when the printing press was invented
before that the church had complete
control over
literature which was the bible basically
right then the printing press comes
along and suddenly you've got the
ability to make a newspaper and a lot of
the people who now own a newspaper are
not people who had any control over that
space before right so you've got
essentially the same thing happening now
where people like us are creating new
platforms now you're going to get your
own platform where you've got the
entertainment you've got the comedy
you've got the movies you've got the
political analysis and that and i think
a lot of the the companies that are
going to get built in the next five
years they're going to be the next big
things that actually end up being some
of the biggest contributors to this
space and you're part of it well you
know what what's fascinating is
the amount of money that netflix spends
on making a show makes me just laugh i
know because you can you can make good
shows really really cheaply right and so
i i'm not going to to to claim that the
shows we have on tps.com are the
greatest shows of all time no they're
better than that and everybody should
sign up
uh i think i think we start it's a
little rough and we're trying to just
earn our place into doing better and
better and better better and figure out
what works
and um
it's it's it's relatively cheap it's
expensive don't get me wrong but
compared to what amazon and netflix and
hulu pay for shows
i'm just like
we can sustain a full show with only a
few thousand paying members whereas
netflix has like what a ridic like tens
of millions or something like that and
then their shows they're like it cost us
millions to make and then we canceled it
i'm like we could make a show
and it
we we could make some show some podcasts
we can make a podcast that only has 1
000 paying members for the podcast and
the podcast can exist forever because
that thousand thousand members i mean
that's that's ten thousand bucks a month
then we pay the podcast toast and
they're they're good there you go we
made the investment your shows forever
so if there are people who like the show
and there are people who like the job
and that's the best the show can do why
cancel it and then i look at these other
networks and they cancel it and i'm like
oh if if the fans sustain the show the
show can be forever this is what's
interesting about
the way the the model used to be that tv
shows and cable needed a certain number
of viewers otherwise they were canceled
and the fans would be like no don't
cancel they're sorry 300 000 fans isn't
enough because the ad dollars doesn't
pay for this show
if those 300 000 fans paid 10 bucks a
month for the show the show would be
making a massive profit
and then they'd be able to make the show
even better i think this is why the
daily wire made made the big shift and
they're focusing on vod content because
they were like
you don't need that many people to
support you to make a massive platform
and be successful so that's what i saw
too and i said the ad model is less
effective than the the passion model so
let's just make content that works i
thought of it like this i was like you
know we've been treating it like a
bakery trying to give away a million
free cakes and then telling a business
but we'll put your name on the cake
and pay for us instead of just being
like hey the kit costs five bucks you
know if you if you want it buy it so
we're doing a two-pronged approach for
sure we want to make free content pop
culture crisis you can watch it there's
super chats tim castillo it's free you
can watch it there's super chats and
then we direct you to the premium model
con you know stuff where it's like hey
if you like it buy it yeah it's awesome
and this is how you change the culture
and that's why i'm going to make you an
optimist by the end of this conversation
well this is how you change the culture
and then things will change well so i
guess i guess my point is i'm not
entirely convinced that
what's to come is going to be
when i say civil war
um
i don't know if it's gonna it's gonna be
the way people the way it used to be
like a fifth generational civil war is
people posting memes online
this could be it right the fact that we
do shows we argue our points and other
people go on tv and lie and try to
manipulate that could be the extent to
which war exists internally in in our in
the modern era because violence actually
turns people off when black lives matter
after george floyd was killed black
lives matter net support hit like 50
something percent it was crazy 50 like
that's nuts and then they rioted and it
tanked to like nine percent net support
they lost all of their pr gains violence
did not work and so i'm like
you know what does work is false flags
like framing your enemy or
you just make something more fun more
entertaining and something people want
to be a part of so it could be that the
conflict we're in this is the peak
culmination of it and it doesn't get to
the point where it's you know people
shooting each other or something yeah
even i'm not that optimistic but i hear
what you're saying yeah well i'm saying
maybe i don't know yeah yeah what i do
know is that we're in a conflict
and you can call whatever you want no
question well there are huge shifts i
mean netflix it lost like 1.3 million
u.s and canadian subscribers recently
people don't like whatever system is out
there and the daily wire is at a million
yeah well this is what i don't think
they approach them a lot about right is
what has the internet enabled and i
think what it has done is it's you know
how tv is by definition fake
do you know what i mean like people are
sitting in a fake place where they don't
hang out and it's fake in every way
right and what happens with podcasting
and things like that is we kind of
weaponized authenticity like people
watching the show know that i'm saying
what i'm saying because that's what i
believe and you're saying what you're
saying because that's what you believe
and they may dislike what i'm saying or
they may dislike what you're saying but
they at least know it's authentic
so the internet has enabled that
authenticity in a way that wasn't
possible before and that's what's making
the difference and that's why people
will happily pay a subscription fee for
something otherwise they would never pay
for it's like reality tv was just
literally not reality a hundred percent
right and this is reality tv because if
the cameras were off we'd still be
having this conversation i mean we were
having part of this conversation before
the camera's turned that's my point and
then usually it's really funny because
when we're getting ready we're doing
pre-production for the show we have
conversations that i'm like we probably
could have recorded and just used
because it was really good but
we never let our guests talk about
anything before we do the interview
because that's where the interesting
stuff always gets said if we're not
recording do you know what i mean well
for us um it's mostly current events
yeah so we just have the news stories
lined up and then we're like you know we
like we can talk about whatever for
depending on the guests one thing we try
to do is like if the guest has a
specialty or a certain thing they really
want to hit on then we'll we'll do news
and then at nine we'll get a half an
hour in of just like which reminds me
you have a book you do i want to know
about this what what's the premise well
i talk about growing up in the soviet
union i talk about my grandmother being
born in the gulag i talk about my
grandfather being a slave uh during
those times and i'm trying to con we're
not trying to i'm contrasting many of
the things that i see in modern society
in the west now with the things that my
family went through and i'm saying
like i've been saying to you but when
you agree with me this is not a good
path to go down right and most people
don't understand that the path where
going down has you know all the eastern
europeans i talked to in the west they
all say the same thing like we've seen
this before
so give you one example do you guys know
where political correctness comes from
where does it come from the soviet union
right so in the soviet union they would
say to you comrade what you're saying is
virtually correct but it's politically
incorrect right and what that meant was
you were not following the party line
does that sound unfamiliar that's
exactly what's happening well that's
exactly what's happening soc said that
remember exactly morally correct right
and what it meant was you were factually
incorrect but you were morally correct
or vice versa yeah and so political
correctness is simply a way of getting
people to do what you want that's what
it is and so when i see the shutting
down of freedom of conversation the
shutting down of freedom of research the
inability of scientists to say their
opinion about a medical treatment or
whatever that worries me not because i'm
just like i am in favor of that
treatment or against that dream i'm just
worried because to me that's like an
alarm bell
it's an alarm bell and the same thing
you know my grandfather i talked about
this in the book he uh was a he was a
soviet dissident you could say he said
in the 1980s that the soviet union was
wrong to invent afghanistan
immediately lost his job
ostracized by his friends many of whom
tim you'll like this by the way said no
no we agree with you we just can't do it
in public did you see the cartoon where
the guy's burning the moment at the
stake and he says by the way incredible
i agree with everything you said
how did your grandfather speak out
publicly in the age he didn't speak out
publicly he said in a private
conversation someone reported him
familiar too right and then and then
that's what happened well i'll tell you
a story uh i was when i was staying in
ukraine staying at my friend's house
and it was old communist block housing
right it's like reappropriated as like
apartments and she said
during the during the soviet union
the neighbors next door
were feuding with the people who lived
here they were arguing or something
nonsense so the people who lived here
called the party and said my neighbor
has disparaged the party the next day
their apartment was empty and they
weren't gone right but that's what
people used to do that's what people
used to do man and this is one you know
the last part of the book the the my
warning to people this is why i'm trying
to hit that middle man because you're
not going to get the crazies on either
side you're not going to get to them
you're not going to persuade them
they're crazy that's that's the point
right but the vast majority of people
you can persuade and and that's what you
know i'm trying to tell them the story
so
my grandmother born in a gulag and i
don't know if you know this but if once
you were released from the gulag
um
you wouldn't be allowed to live in any
major city in the country you had to
leave to live in a small town in the
countryside and the only people that
lived in these siberian towns or the
miles out of the way of anything were
former guards from the gulags
and former prisoners wow
right next to each other yeah right next
to each other in 1953 i think stalin
dies
and nikita khrushchev comes in and he's
he he denounces everything that had
happened he says stalin was wrong the
purges were wrong this was not communism
blah blah blah blah and he reveals many
of the crimes that stalin and his people
did
and you know what happened in that small
town where my grandma lived
dozens
of those former gulag guards
shot themselves whoa because they were
like holy
what was i part of yeah right and that's
all i'm saying to people in the west
don't be a useful idiot do not go along
with things that you do not believe
because you're afraid do not go along
with things that you do not believe
because you're going to lose your job do
not go along with things and don't
demonize people you're not a good i
don't care if you put hashtag be kind
before you said kill yourself doesn't
make you a good person i'm sure some of
those guards shot themselves because
they were scared of what other people
would do to them when they found out
what they were doing i don't think they
were man because nothing happened to
them they they just realized what they'd
been a part of they had a wake-up call
and this is what i'm saying to people
who are going along with whether it's
cancer culture or demonizing people or
attacking people online like we have a
friend in london we had him on the show
james cavarini he runs the oldest
family-run italian restaurant in london
he did a fundraiser for ukrainian
orphans with jk rowling
next day bunch of one star reviews on
tripadvisor the day after i'm not saying
it's connected but this is what happened
next day someone smashes in the windows
of his restaurant wow you're not a good
person you're not standing up for anyone
if that's what you're doing you're
you're a bad person and you're going
along with an ideology that is making
you a terrible person don't do it but
that's what i'm trying to say to people
i've i've i've had so many conversations
these antivites
a lot of them just don't care they're
not trying to be good people they think
it's funny that's why i'm saying i don't
care about them you're never going to
reach those people but there's people
when they break the law they need to go
to prison they need to serve their time
and that's one of the problems we have
on our society the law is not uniformly
enforced but this this also means that
we need to be
less naive
when it comes to the people who seek to
exploit our kindness agreed there was a
there's a woman that i knew who worked
for a major publication
and uh she was an activist we were
hanging out at another you know
prominent activist place
and she told me that she just likes
watching the world burn but she doesn't
really care she said she's a total
nihilist and she was like but don't you
just want to see it shaken up and burn
and i was like no
because i was saying like i understand
the nihilism i feel i feel a bit
nihilistic myself but you know the idea
that nothing matters means that you need
to make things matter you need to make
things good and better and important and
her attitude was no if it doesn't matter
just burn it and watch it's fun yeah
there are people like that and that's
why i'm saying you're not going to reach
a person like that because by virtue of
the psychology trauma experience
whatever you want i understand my point
is you are competing against them no
you're not because we're competing for
the middle that's what i'm saying
they're going to the middle yeah and who
do you think they're going to choose a
sensible person who says actually maybe
just because your three-year-old said
the other gender yeah but but you
misunderstand
their what they're doing is they're
taking a clip of you
quoting stalin and claiming you you said
it and then the person in the middle
goes i heard that guy constantly saying
he wanted to lock people up who
disagreed with him like that was freaky
and then you're like i didn't say that
that's a fake clip and then go bro i
watched the video you're lying they told
me you were gonna lie to me but the the
secret weapon in the culture war this
fifth generational world war is the
authenticity because like the the news
media will shove
antifa's message or whatever this
message is called message down people's
throat but it's like look at this
cardboard box it looks like a house it's
a house look how beautiful this house is
and people are like i know it's not but
they're telling me it is
looks cool i'll go along with it i'm not
going to say anything but then they hear
us and they're like oh these people are
real
and then it's in dispute you cannot
dispute in disputation
right i mean
look at rogan cnn went after him
do you think most people believe rogan
or do they think they believe cnn cnn's
viewers are in the gutter but their
viewers believed him sure cnn viewers
believed him right right but who does
who does the sensible middle believe
that's what i'm that's what we're
talking about this is fascinating too
the i i have friends who are relatively
woke that like these are people like
people i knew from a long time ago in
chicago and then the last time i went on
rogan you look at their profiles and
it's blm it's the black square it's
pride flags and they're hitting me up
saying like that was awesome you're so
great like it's good to hear from you
and then i'm just like it's weird to me
because like
all of the stuff you believe in but you
heard me and you understand that like i
wonder if that's gonna change your mind
but at the very least
they listen to rogan they trust rogan
they believe
that's why i'm optimistic somewhat
because do you know how many people i
get that i used to gig with on the
comedy circuit who hated me who
complained about me who criticized me
when i turned down this contract blah
blah blah do you know how many of them
hit me up now going oh i love your show
all of them that's what's happening man
not
not all of them but a lot of them right
so i i think that there is a sensible
majority to be won over that's what i
believe and that's what i'm trying to do
we're going to go to super chats and i
really i want to give a quick shout out
to adrian curry because we're big fans
and she said reality tv was reality
until 2003 then it died
reality wasn't good enough for them
well i think the reality was they tried
reality tv they had a positive response
and then said hey
it's just cheaper to fake this stuff
so i explained this to people about
youtube you'd see these videos on
youtube where like a guy saves a
homeless person
and it's like he brings them food and
they hug and it's like oh he gets 10
million views now you have the story of
that woman she's got a year in jail a
year in prison because she faked the
homeless man gave me 20 his last 20 so i
could eat and it was like scam and they
raised money
what happens is these youtubers were
like somebody made a real video we're
like i'm gonna go help homeless people
and then they filmed it and put it up
and it was okay and then someone else
said why bother trying to find a
homeless person when i can pay a guy 20
bucks to pretend to be homeless and get
it done in an hour so they just started
faking it was faster and easier
but let's read some super chats
everybody
all right if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
us for everything i explained a moment
ago that we're uh we've got tales from
the inverted world it's a fascinating
show to put on on like a sunday night
with the lights turned low and you're
getting ready for bed and you just let
it play and it's a spooky story and it's
fun stuff and then we got a pop culture
crisis we got cass castle morticom
chicken city i'm really excited we're
going to have our rooster roberto junior
and a times square billboard yeah he
deserves it he definitely does he's a
superstar he's an employer of the month
every every month great father employee
of the month absolutely all right here
we go
the chronicles of chris says
lol the thumbnail looks like kissing
told a stupid joke that tim disliked
also did you read the capitalism article
i told you about in the hotep episode i
did not i did not have to look into it
um and remind me of which capitalism
article that was
raymond g magga stanley jr says
tim so today i directly sent handcuffs
and heat resistant gloves to aoc's dc
headquarters with a nice gift note for
each i wonder if the feds will visit me
oh that'll be interesting i suppose
aoc advocated for using heat races and
gloves in protest so you know
grafti says love you all buck buck buck
in the ad we have with roberto junior on
it it just very quickly says buck buck
down like the side like in really small
and then it's two adds actually so the
one on the right side is the cartoon
version of roberto and roberto jr and
the anime fighting it's really funny i'm
really excited for that
all right
were you always a big chicken fan sorry
oh yeah chickens are awesome i when i
lived in miami chickens and then the
neighbor dog kept kept uh killing them
and i was getting really angry because
it was like digging in and i'm like what
the like we had this closed off area
with chickens in it and they were i was
pissed i was really mad and we
confronted the neighbor and then he
bought us new chickens and the dog kept
trying to break in so then you know we
didn't know it was a dog at first so we
put up a trap caught the dog and then
returned the dog to people i was like
look at your dog
yeah
anyway we gotta we gotta just remember
my first couple days working here you
the chickens were at the front of the
house at the time they didn't have their
like sweet estate that they have now and
you would be like and this is sarah and
this is like you knew all of their names
and i'm like i don't okay they all sort
of look brown and that one's got oh i
know their names so the originals all
have good names and then some of their
kids have names like roberto jr is like
the best and there's like maggie and
bernie and um isaac but um most of the
new chickens we haven't named because
they're just two men there's so many of
them yeah it's like 30 or 40. my family
used to have turkeys uh on the phone oh
turkeys and they'd give them names and
we had two really big ones that were
very aggressive and would always fight
each other and my family having their
sense of humor that they do they named
one adolph another one joseph
[Laughter]
brilliant
all right dalen smythe says thank you
for restoring a bit of my faith in some
form i don't believe in a god as a
person but as a construct the system
everything think multiverse different
types of infinity and dimensions beyond
perception and that's in line with what
people refer to as einsteinian god
the idea that there is a greater power
of some sort but it's not a person and
that that's that's more so where i fall
into into thinking i don't know what
what you ian or or you constantly well
we were having this exact conversation
before we started right yeah and i think
lydia asked me if i believe in god and i
said like no and then i was like hold on
no no no that's not what i mean like i
don't believe in a dude in the sky uh
but i do believe in something above us
all that connects us as human beings for
sure yeah ghost crusader says ian i
missed you yesterday and i love your
shirt that is stolos he teaches
astronomy and the knowledge of poisonous
plants herbs and precious stones is this
is this uh this is stollus this it's an
owl let me see if you guys can see that
is that in the shot right there
beautiful seems like a rad dude somebody
sent this to me whoever that is thank
you so much and there's gems on it as
well is that why you like it
that's the main reason
all right
friedrich borman says constantine has
two good videos with michael svetov on
sv tv channel i recommend them for
russian speakers and if you can
translate them read subtitles for
english speakers as well
what is that about uh so the michael
svetov is a russian youtuber and i think
politician and he interviewed me a
couple of times about how i see what's
happening in russia ukraine wow yeah and
he's in russia uh he's not in russia
okay i was going to say like
not anymore no no no no but he's a cool
guy and then we had a couple of great
conversations for sure yeah like so just
really quickly on that i mean what's the
risk if you were in russia and you were
critical of what what they're doing are
they going to come after you are they
going to try and shut you down uh so do
you know what happens to protesters in
russia gulag
no gulag anymore but so when when russia
first invaded ukraine people went out in
groups to protest that was illegal they
got arrested locked up etc then they
went out in what they called single
pickets that you go out on your own with
a sign saying no war arrested arrested
then
people started going out with no sign
just holding hands up in the air
pretending to have a sign
as they get arrested and the best one
was there was a dude whose name is zamir
which you might know in russian means
for peace right
and he was in an airport standing with
the with his name on a plaque on like a
little piece of cardboard or whatever
his name means for peace and if you
stand with the with the things that says
for peace you're in favor of peace that
means you're against the war in ukraine
arrested but he was like waiting for
someone to get yeah he was just that was
his name did you did you see the uh
there was a woman who was pro-invasion
yeah she walks up to the camera to argue
in favor and the cops just grab her in a
restaurant he's like no no i'm
supporting it
right we don't care russia in this
moment is a totalitarian state when it
comes to the issues no question about it
yeah putin's been in power how long uh
he since 1999. so you think about this
when he first came to power we were
worried about the millennium bug
[Laughter]
y2k yup right what was he uh who was uh
he
he wasn't kgb oh do you know how i came
to power it's a very interesting story
you got a quick version yeah i do have a
quick version so basically boris yeltsin
who was the president before him uh
needed someone to replace him that had
no power that had no power because
anyone who came in who already had power
the first thing they do is they put
yeltsin in prison confiscate all his
ill-gotten gains etc so he found this
guy that nobody had heard of like
vladimir putin in russia before he
became president had less profile than
anyone in this room has in america right
now well right no one knew who he was
and he came along he was and boris
yeltsin made him acting prime minister
wow and if you're the incumbent in
russia you know what that means right
you're going to win the election and
then right before the election yeltsin
said actually i'm a bit ill
why don't why doesn't this nice guy take
over and see what we can do and and
that's what he then did with medvedev as
well remember that so putin serves a
couple of terms that's when he's
supposed to leave he puts medvedev in
place medivh comes in changes all the
law so putin can solve more longer terms
and then they do the switcheroo back man
all right let's see
philip reed says i don't know about tim
and the crew but i'm getting sick and
tired of waking up to major historical
events
you're in it yeah but you know what that
was reality it was like bro you were in
a golden age and that's why you weren't
in historical events like
now you are the major historian well no
no life was always you know in this
country and everywhere else it was
always a historical moment something big
was happening but things got so soft and
so protected in the united states that
we had a period where nothing was
happening and we were like this is great
no the natural state of the world is is
historical yeah when you wake up are you
looking to be told what's going on in
the world are you looking to tell the
world what's going on
you know
pick one or do both all right
let's see jeff house says your intent is
wrong tim he was open-handed going for
the mic near his face with a non-bladed
cat ears less lethal weapon nbc news
youtube channel 134 zoomed in clip loved
the show too much to let you get sued
for libel over small details well um
we can't be sued for a libel over
reading a news article that said he
tried he went for his neck and it's also
opinion statement yeah i also don't
think he has said what his intent was
right like right we're not sure but i
don't think that matters if a guy goes
up on stage holding cat ears if that's
what they're called and
reaches around for someone's neck or
whatever you're allowed to interpret
that that being said
if it turns out i'm wrong
uh outright okay but this is not a
covington catholic situation where we
got a small snippet i watched the video
the guy walk up on stage and go around
and reach around and i saw the thing in
his hands and then i read the reports
and i'm like
i don't know what he was trying to so i
understand maybe why it was second
degree attempted assault and that does
explain it so you know i will accept
that for sure
i still think
we got to be careful with this stuff
right
yeah i don't know if i want to argue i
just don't think i really want this
scenario playing out all the time like
this is wild that he just like strolled
onto stage and was like i'm going to
carry a weapon and that's it that's okay
and if his intent really was to try and
do a slow roll
you know next shot or something but
masquerade as i'm just going for the
microphone that's all i'm doing you know
what i mean
so
don't go up on stage with a with a
weapon of any kind and then reach around
at the guy
i don't want to apologize for what we
what we saw happen considering how
dangerous things are getting but you
know fair point fair point jeff house i
appreciate it
all right michael
uh tim cisco says tim have you uh tim
you have to get colleen noir or mark
smith from the four boxes diner on the
show
i mean we'd love to get colleen noir on
the show whenever he can
that'd be fantastic
c recipe says i had almost 300 000 subs
and 60 million views on youtube and they
deleted my channel just informed talk
two weeks before 2020 election in
youtube purge i've started over with a
cooking show see recipes any help for us
well follow see recipes i suppose i know
a couple other channels that youtube
deleted without cause it's insane
isn't it oh c recipes is it the letter c
or the letter c see all one word yeah
see recipes do they like what do they
send you do they send you like an email
being like well the people the people i
saw know their accounts are just gone
and they were like no one talked to them
alan smith says one thing to remember
about with the possibility of an alien
invasion is the cross-contamination of
viruses
yes but why wouldn't a virus of an alien
build a jump species like
dogs get sick we don't huma as far as i
know crappy wrong do humans get parvo
they don't right
hey there's a lab in wuhan that can help
yeah oh yeah you know my theory is that
kovit's here to protect us from the next
alien invasion it's going to kill all
the aliens because they don't have a
resistance to it but we've already built
up one
are going to give them covet blankets i
don't think is going to give i don't
think the aliens will have the
appropriate receptors to take on human
viruses or vice versa we'll find out i
just think like even if an alien life
form comes down and they seem peaceful
like they are so fundamentally different
from us like do we really think
it would be a sustainable pairing
forever like what if they eat their
young and they're like but we just eat
our own well you have a spare human
child could i just like have it it
didn't go well for them it just doesn't
make sense
all right tyler price says the aztecs
and them believed the spanish were the
return of quesacotil one of their gods
that was prophesized to come back then
were slaughtered that's it yes and the
aztecs also did ritualistic human
sacrifice too so it's like
just a couple of bad groups it's kind of
why you also want to shake out of like
fantasy mode of any kind whether it's
like whatever you believe guy in the sky
floating like if aliens do come don't
mistake it for like god because that's
like we got to take it very seriously it
could be an invading force but also
don't be
flipped out by the when cnn tells you
there's an invading force because there
may not be one mike s says tim could you
please ask your eu guest what is a woman
not a human female
[Laughter]
it's fairly simple actually yeah
all right
uh uh eraftis of stets says my dog roxy
just died today and i just wanted
everyone to know she was the best little
dog in the world and i'll miss her sorry
to hear man it's already here
shout out to roxy
bad penny says i hate when people talk
about aliens and compare them to what
happened to the indians but they are
alien they could just like studying new
life forms spin the ufo unrelated would
love to see jimmy from bright insight on
sometime i would love to see jimmy we
talk about atlantis spinning that
atlantis
what is youtube doing here
all right michael says howdy tim and
crew consting doesn't seem to understand
how divided the united states really is
how will we find any compromise with the
far left extremists when they're not
even willing to engage in civil
discourse well we've sort of covered it
first of all i think i'm well aware of
how divided that was kind of my point
right uh i but that's why i never you
when we were having that conversation i
never use the word compromise because i
don't think it's about compromising with
the work extremists i think it's about
hitting that sensible middle that i was
talking about right you're never going
to compromise with the extremists on
either side because it's not possible
they're extremists yeah
i think i think the solution is
get people away from these big
corporations and let the work work
corporations suffer under their wokeness
get well go broke
do your thing look at uh jeremy's razors
man
harry's was like we're canceling and
they're like we're gonna make our own
razor company and then they did
and now they're rivaling and competing
with these companies is absolutely
brilliant
hugh jennings says
david dorn's killer was convicted that's
right glad to see it some accountability
not across the board but enough so you
know or i should say enough there at
least
all right
dano says ian please bring some actual
meaningful conversation
we are tired of hearing you correct
everyone's grammar okay let's talk about
poly
poly let's talk about microfragmentation
coral microfragmentation right now they
say the coral reefs are dying off if you
shatter coral into hundreds thousands of
pieces call it microfragmentation of
coral it all grows together and you can
reform the coral reefs fast you get this
polycultural microfragmentation because
coral reefs are lots of different animal
species living together corals and
animal so you need a lot of different
cultures of coral when we regrow the
coral reefs that's what i was about to
say you want to give people hope that's
why i'm here science is cool it's what
yeah yes all right john uh jendesse says
four thousand fired replacements in
place before he takes office do your
research oh okay
brian page says please buy billboards
along i-95 and rhode island we need more
people listening to tim cast in this
tiny democrat wasteland
oh okay island
you know the thing about billboards is
they're like extremely
regionally you know targeting and it's
like
is rhode island really going to you know
is that really a market we should be
buying ads in yes
because we got to plant the seeds whose
shade we know we may never sit beneath
and it's the summer right now so if
you're in new england you go to rhode
island to go to the beach so you're
right a lot of regional traffic three
miles wide
it's like more than that but i'm
exaggerating it's microscopic so like a
nice three thousand dollar billboard for
a month all over the country just tons
of three thousand dollar billboards and
like semi-rural no those would cost like
three hundred dollars that would be epic
let's do like ten thousand three hundred
dollar billboards suburban and rural
billboards are really cheap
like it might be what it's at next we
had a there there was a billboard bought
out here and i think it was 300 bucks
like west virginia billboard was like
300 bucks from for i think it was for
like a month
that'd be cool yeah so times square i'll
let you guys in on some secrets
ridiculously cheap really ridiculously
cheap you can get uh like ten dollars
per per play
so they're digital billboards so there
are some agencies where you can get you
know a 25 foot screen and it's 10 bucks
per run with a 10 run minimum minimum so
it's like 100 bucks and then you go
stand in front of it your ad plays you
get a picture of it and there you go now
if you want like a month
is when you're going to start getting
into the tens of thousands of dollars so
some of those bigger billboards can be
you know like
the bigger ones that are up high 30
grand for a month
that's the big the most expensive one i
think is that it's like the tower or
something it's 625 000 per week
massive super huge like what is it like
100 200 feet or something like that it's
so iconic right and so the thing is
people someone pointed out that there's
a uh a resident evil tick tock
for their ad in time square and you can
see the edge of the tim cast one in it
that's why you buy times square dang
those 3d billboards have you guys been
seeing those those are cool right i
don't know what they look like in person
i still haven't seen one
we saw when we were in new york oh it
was right there actually you're right
yeah those things are stunning yeah it's
super cool
it wraps around and then it was like a
robot yeah it looks like it's coming out
at you it's crazy yeah it's super cool
those are fun
all right
mr dad folks says no unemployment these
bloodsuckers have sapped enough from the
american people they need to find a job
asap if they want to keep a
million-dollar roof over their heads
woof
spicy i know the desire i keep thinking
about you actually brought up shae's
rebellion last night thank you because
in that instance it was john hancock
that pardoned all those farmers um and i
think it's we're in the age of maybe
another round of pardons against whoever
you think your enemies might be right
now kind of got to move forward together
we don't gotta but i'd like to all right
milo hoffman says you don't replace a
cancer tumor when you remove it fire
them all some if something needs done
the states can do it
yeah you know people are saying things
like
like oh no who's going to trump's going
to replace these people with and i'm
like i kind of feel like less government
is a good thing you know like
i don't inherently think less like it's
less government across the board let's
figure it out
storm viking says chris hayes on msnbc
was just just was lying through his
whole segment saying the capital officer
was killed by rioters and saying donald
trump didn't condemn the rioting throw
some more gen 6bs in wow
how many news outlets lied about cops
dying on january 6.
crazy
apparently the new york times
there that story about the cop having
the stroke or whatever
the narrative was that he was hitting
that with a fire extinguisher then you
find out later it's just like it wasn't
true
he had like a stroke the next day and
they're like oh that whoop yeah well
then for a while they're saying like the
stress of the day's events triggered
these things that wouldn't have
happened without them i mean yeah yeah
the federal reserve that was how i got
my first weed card there i was like
tension stress they're like what's
stressing you out yeah federal reserves
you got it buddy
san francisco james nelson says once he
declares start naming appointees he
would put in place and have them start
lining up staff so day one they can swap
out the corrupt lifers then move
agencies to cities across america
all right
i dig it
didn't they move the department of the
interior to colorado and then they're
like we're going to move back to dc
though this isn't working that's crazy
all right
catoth swiss says this guy speaks as if
the left is rational and open a
conversation i suppose ignorance is
bliss where is the uk in regards to the
groomer gangs
well it's an issue we've covered on our
show extensively we've just had a report
come out which confirmed what happened
but yeah
this is the problem right we had do you
know what they are the grooming gangs no
yeah yeah yeah once again especially
with when tommy robinson was covering it
yeah a lot of people got arrested yeah
yeah so so what happened was basically
for decades uh gangs of men
predominantly of south asian background
so i think pakistani and
bangladeshi i think
were
basically finding vulnerable
predominantly white and sikh girls
who were not adults usually and
raping them for years
there were a few that were actually
killed during this process and what
compounded that problem is
uh the police the local councils the
authorities
they
didn't do anything about it because of
quote unquote sensitivities about race
wow right uh we interviewed a woman a
brave woman called dr lahill who was one
of the victims of these uh so the videos
on our channel uh about it uh yeah well
it's a terrible thing and it happened
i think it's still happening to some
extent uh but again
it takes time and it's awful that it
happened uh but we are even on that
issue slowly making a bit of progress
because now it's being talked about but
uh i remember tommy robinson he was what
was he there for he was there when they
were sentencing or something like that
one in one of these cases they arrested
him for right uh they arrested him for
breaking the law around reporting on
criminal cases yeah and you can't that's
insane to me
what law did they say brock i i don't
remember the details right now i think
it's something to do with the way that
you cover cases which haven't been
finalized
um but so so you know it's been a while
i could be totally wrong my
understanding was that the case was the
trial was done and it was like
sentencing or something like that and
they're like we don't care you can't do
this and apparently he asked for
permission he was like is it okay if i
come if i'm like yeah and then he walks
over and then okay you're under arrest
he's like what i don't it was a long
time ago i don't remember the exact
details but i i don't remember it quite
that way but i mean i'm pretty sure he
asked i'm pretty sure he was like i said
okay if i film they're like yeah he's
like all right and then they came late
like maybe a supervisor was like no no
arrest him
i don't know man the stuff i've seen
with tommy robinson the government
really
was screwing around to put it simply
but to me like the idea that you
couldn't report on a trial is crazy you
know like as an american
like standing outside of a court and
like reporting i mean you want you want
crazy i'll give you an example we had a
comedian called joe lysa it was
investigated by the police for a joke he
did because an audience maybe you want
crazy we got crazy yeah in the uk we got
crazy but this is why we declared
independence you know right
right but we don't have a first
amendment
yeah i know it's a big it's a big
problem
yeah man i i remember following a lot of
these stories with um was it speaker's
corner or what is it called yeah
speakers people were getting like
arrested or carted away and stuff it's
like well we've got we've got police
officers calling people up and saying
you posted this thing on twitter we need
to check your thinking wow right check
your thinking what a terrible break a
guy called harry miller
all right
scouty says tim and team you're my
favorite podcast but please have on some
actual atheists to explain their
positions there's been a lot of straw
manning albeit incidental i can email
some suggestions thanks for all you do
uh i would love to get i mean we've had
atheists on the show we we've literally
the the quotes i've made about the
atheists we've had
uh i'm sorry the quotes i've said about
atheists have been the ones who are on
the show and said things but
none of these people i think were like
atheists
theologians or you know um religious
scholars
so that would be interesting like
agnostic i want a gnostic on the show
wuzzo says in your 4 p.m segment you
said swamp monsters my wife and i
immediately jumped into the chorus of
swamp monsters to the tune of rock
lobster so a monster we should write
that song
uh okay we'll grab we'll grab some more
super chits
all right
bobcat says why does tim keep preaching
generational warfare as if that theory
is any relation or reality it's being
debunked in iraq afghanistan in the 2020
insurrection seriously get an actual
shooter on what are you talking about
like generational warfare describes
things that are literally happening
get a shooter on why would you do that
what does that mean
i don't know like like an actual combat
vet or something um
generational warfare refers to
advancements and tactics and warfare and
they're real
so like just because fifth generational
warfare is happening doesn't mean third
generational warfare doesn't exist
anymore it still does i think the
military actually claimed there used to
be three theaters of war land sea and
air and then there were four which was
land sea air and cyber now there's five
well cyber cyber and space were one what
it was land sea air well actually air
space land sea air and space and cyber
and then now spirituality is a fifth
theater of war i saw a four-star general
talking about it let's see if i can pull
that up for a later show huh yeah the
spiritual
theater this is actual military doctrine
as far as i was told mitch says tim
would love for tim cass to have apps for
roku et cetera is there any plan yes
okay so we are like a tiny fraction of
the size of the daily wire but um
we have to get more members and get
bigger we've got like one dev and it's
expensive so we've been slowly rolling
out technological advancements to the
site to improve things it's a
particularly rudimentary system that
we've built
we're we're doing well we're hiring more
people we just like literally hired i
think like two or three more people with
more people on the way
it is difficult you know i think we're
approaching like 35 employees and so we
need managerial power but then
managerial power costs a lot of money
and so it's like we can only grow as
fast as we can grow
and
i'll put this way if we had the roku
apps we'd probably get way more members
to make the roku app we need to grow to
a point where we can hire a couple devs
to make to build it out and so
we're we're like effective we're
bursting at the seams we can only go as
fast as humans can go and budget
constraints allow
and as you expand you grow in every
direction so it's like we get a dev we
get roku all of a sudden now we need
content to fill it so we you know we
just start expanding long story short we
want roku we want chromecast we want uh
apple we want uh lg tv samsung tv all
those apps take a long time to do and we
need a mobile app we were working on the
mobile app that fell through because
we were a relatively small operation and
we are
i imagine it like we have a 10-ton
boulder with a chain and we are pulling
that boulder uphill we can only go so
fast but the more people who line up
behind it and start pushing on that
boulder the faster we move up that
mountain hopefully in five years we're
gonna we're gonna be bigger than disney
plus and people are gonna be like i
cancelled disney plus i'm just you know
it's just tim cass and daily wire for me
that's what we're hoping for so uh i
will say this smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share this show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com if you like the shows we do
if you want to see the uncensored after
show you can follow us at timcast irl
you can follow me at tim cass
constantine do you want to shout
anything out i'm on at constance and
kissing and of course the show is
trigonometry and by my book and
immigrants love letter to the west where
would they buy that amazon okay
i'm hannah brimlow you can see me on
tim cash click on the read tab i write
five articles a day and you can find me
on instagram i'm hannah claire dot b ian
crossland ian crossland.net hit me up on
social media and if you want to follow
up on what i was talking about by the
general the four-star general talking
about the theaters of war and the
advancement it's called the future of
war this is the video uh the future of
war and how it affects you it's by
smarter every day destin brilliant man
and i found it you know you can search
youtube for the future of war smarter
every day it's a 25-minute 28-minute
documentary that he did with his general
it's fantastic see you later
very cool thanks you guys so much for
tuning in this evening you guys can
follow me on twitter and minds.com at
sourpatchlitz as well as
sourpatchlids.me
we will see all of you on any one of our
shows check out youtube.com castcastle
though it is becoming a much bigger show
and we'll be moving to youtube i want to
clarify something for everybody
what we want to do so so hold on listen
i go on chicken city right
chickencitylive.com
and we have these funny cartoons the
latest one we did was we asked an ai to
write a story and it wrote a story about
ian being a chicken it gets like 60 000
views and i'm like man that's huge
we have cast castle with funny jokes
here's what we want to do on the youtube
channel we want to put up like a minute
gag video or like a two minute video
short or something you know special from
the space and then the website we're
gonna have the full show so that's the
plan you can also check out
chickencitylife.com and you can check
out timcast.com for tales from the
inverted world it's been a blast hanging
out with all of you this week we'll be
back live on monday thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all then
you